Justina Tedesco knows exactly when she got the idea to leave suburban New Jersey and move to a different state. It was still at the height of COVID. Her second-grader was doing remote learning. The vaccine had barely been introduced, and most people couldn't get it.
Justina Tedesco 清楚地记得她是何时萌生了离开新泽西州郊区搬到另一个州的念头。那时正处于新冠疫情最严重的时期，她的二年级孩子还在上网课。疫苗才刚刚推出，大多数人还打不上。
She was working from home, and her son's class took a snack break.
她当时在家工作，她儿子的班级刚好休息吃零食。
So we would usually go into the kitchen, grab a snack. And on the TV was, of course, Fox News. And DeSantis was on the TV talking about the pandemic and how he disapproved of how other states were handling things. And he said, he goes, well, since we're handling things so differently, if you're not happy in the state you live in, come to Florida. We welcome you here.
我们通常会去厨房拿点零食，电视上放的当然是福克斯新闻（Fox News）。德桑蒂斯（DeSantis）在电视上谈论疫情，说他不同意其他州处理问题的方式。他说，既然我们要处理的方式截然不同，如果你对自己居住的州不满意，那就来佛罗里达州吧，我们欢迎你。
If you look at home sales, I mean, it's pretty clear that people are viewing Florida as a landing pad.
如果你看看房屋销售情况，很明显，人们正把佛罗里达州视为一个落脚点。
When we looked up the clip, DeSantis didn't exactly tell people to move to Florida. But you can see how Justina took it that way.
当我们查看那个片段时，德桑蒂斯并没有确切地告诉人们搬到佛罗里达州。但你可以看出 Justina 是如何理解的。
You know, Tucker, it's interesting. As this went on, I would encounter people, particularly in September, that would move from parts of the country, say, look, they closed our schools. I want-- your schools are open. I'm going to come here because you guys are doing it right. And I really do think these lockdowns have driven some people to Florida who just had enough with these draconian, ineffective restrictions.
你知道，塔克（Tucker），这很有趣。随着时间的推移，我遇到了一些人，特别是在九月，他们从全国各地搬来，说：“看，他们关闭了我们的学校。我想……你们的学校是开放的。我要搬到这里，因为你们做得对。”我确实认为这些封锁措施迫使一些人搬到了佛罗里达州，他们对这些严苛且无效的限制已经受够了。
I don't know, it was like music to our ears. And I thought about it for a second. And I'm like, could you imagine us living in Florida? Could we do it? Could we just pick up everything and move?
我不知道，那听起来就像悦耳的音乐。我考虑了一会儿。我在想，你能想象我们住在佛罗里达州吗？我们能做到吗？我们能收拾好一切搬过去吗？
The big thing she wanted, in-person learning for her son. For Dennis and Alenda Michael, in a small town in Washington State, it was a story on NBC News around the same time that did the job. The story was about a grocery store in Naples, Florida.
她最想要的是让儿子参加线下学习。对于居住在华盛顿州一个小镇的 Dennis 和 Alenda Michael 夫妇来说，大约在同一时间，NBC 新闻的一篇报道起到了作用。那篇报道讲的是佛罗里达州那不勒斯市的一家杂货店。
And it was a hit piece on them because everybody was walking around the store without their mask on.
那是一篇针对他们的批评报道，因为店里的每个人都没戴口罩就在店里走来走去。
In fact, the reporter in the story reads comments from people who saw video of this store online.
事实上，报道中的记者读了一些网友在网上看到这家店的视频后的评论。
Prompting mostly heavy criticism. "I can't stop watching this. My jaw is literally on my desk. This should be a crime. People across the country are dying because of behavior like this." And from a woman mourning her father's death from COVID--
这引发了大部分严厉的批评。“我无法停止观看这个视频，我的下巴简直惊掉在桌子上了。这应该是一种犯罪。全国各地的人们因为这种行为而死去。”还有一位哀悼父亲死于新冠的女士——
And I thought, that's a place I want to be.
我想，那才是我想要去的地方。
Wait, wait, wait. I just want to be sure I understand. There was a story on television saying, look how terrible these people are. They're walking around without masks. And you saw that, and you concluded--
等等，等等，等等。我只是想确保我理解对了。电视上有一篇报道说，看这些人多糟糕啊。他们没戴口罩走来走去。你看到了，然后你就得出结论——
That's where I want to be. The "terrible people part" I ignored because it looked to me like there were people that were enjoying life. And it just was a sense of freedom that we didn't have in Washington State.
那是我想去的地方。我忽略了“糟糕的人”那部分，因为在我看来，那里的人们在享受生活。这正是我们在华盛顿州所没有的一种自由感。
I was curious about all this because in the speeches that Ron DeSantis is giving as he runs for president, he talks a lot about how Florida is the fastest-growing state, which it is. And he talks about how people are moving to Florida because of him and all he's done there, which, who knows?
我对这一切感到好奇，因为罗恩·德桑蒂斯（Ron DeSantis）在竞选总统时发表的演讲中，经常谈到佛罗里达州是增长最快的州，事实确实如此。他还谈到人们因为他和他所做的一切而搬到佛罗里达州，谁知道呢？
It's true that among the transplants, there are twice as many Republicans as Democrats. But I wondered, what is really happening? Was DeSantis actually the reason that people uprooted their lives and crossed the country, like they wanted to be part of his Florida experiment?
事实确实是，在这些移居者中，共和党人是民主党人的两倍。但我很好奇，到底发生了什么？德桑蒂斯真的是人们背井离乡、跨越全国的原因吗，就像他们想参与他的佛罗里达实验一样？
So in the last week, I've talked to a half dozen people who told me, yes, they did exactly that. Though they all said it wasn't just politics. It was also the fact that there's no state income tax in Florida, and housing prices, for nearly all of them, that's way cheaper than where they moved from.
所以在过去一周里，我采访了六个人，他们告诉我，是的，他们确实是这样做的。尽管他们都说这不仅仅是政治原因，还因为佛罗里达州没有州所得税，而且对于他们几乎所有人来说，这里的房价远低于他们搬离的地方。
They love the sunny, summery lifestyle. But they all said politics clinched it, in particular, COVID politics, the way Governor Ron DeSantis broke ranks early and loudly from other states in opening schools and ditching mask mandates. And that's when migration to the state picked up. As one woman, Kim, who moved from Payson, Utah, put it--
他们热爱阳光明媚、充满夏日气息的生活方式。但他们都说政治因素起了决定性作用，尤其是新冠疫情政治，罗恩·德桑蒂斯州长在开放学校和废除口罩强制令方面，很早就大声地与其它州划清了界限。从那时起，迁入该州的人数开始增加。正如从犹他州佩森搬来的 Kim 所说——
We honestly had never even considered Florida prior to COVID.
老实说，在新冠疫情之前，我们甚至从未考虑过佛罗里达州。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah, it had not been on our list at all.
是的，它根本不在我们的名单上。
Justina wanted to get her second-grader on board with the idea of moving. So before they put their house on the market, she sat down with him on the living room couch, and they each put a piece of paper on the coffee table, and each wrote out the pros and cons of going to Florida.
Justina 想让她上二年级的孩子接受搬家的想法。所以，在他们把房子挂牌出售之前，她和他坐在客厅的沙发上，每人在茶几上放了一张纸，写下了搬到佛罗里达州的利弊。
And I said, OK, well, Vincent, let's sit down and let's write down all the things that come to your mind about what makes Florida awesome, and then what we would might miss if we move away from New Jersey. And so he goes, OK.
我说：“好吧，文森特（Vincent），我们坐下来写下你脑海中关于佛罗里达州为什么棒的所有想法，然后写下如果我们离开新泽西州会错过什么。”他说，好的。
So my list started with, obviously, at the top of mine was in-person learning. And then I had on my list, no state income tax. I wrote DeSantis down as one of the items. He was literally just-- his name was listed as number 3. And some of my cons were missing our family, not having the convenience of being able to have babysitters as frequently--
所以我的清单开头，我的首要因素显然是线下学习。然后我的清单上还有没有州所得税。我把德桑蒂斯作为其中一项写了下来。他简直就是——他的名字被列为第三项。而我的一些弊端是想念家人，没有像以前那样方便地请到保姆——
She has a big Italian family living around them in New Jersey.
她的大家族住在新泽西州的周围。
And when I went to go review my son's list, and I said, hey, what do you have, his list had-- his pros were lizards, were on his pros list. And I think I actually had that on my cons list.
当我去检查我儿子的清单时，我说：“嘿，你写了什么？”他的优点清单上有——蜥蜴。我想我实际上把那个写在了我的弊端清单上。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
And on his cons list, he wrote sharks.
而在他的弊端清单上，他写了鲨鱼。
But the most important thing, he didn't write that he would miss his classmates or his school, which told Justina his remote learning experience was so bad, he wasn't bonding with those kids, and they really got to get out of New Jersey and into in-person school.
但最重要的是，他没有写他会想念同学或学校，这告诉 Justina，他的远程学习体验太糟糕了，他与那些孩子没有建立起联系，他们真的必须离开新泽西州，去上实体学校。
While COVID policies were the thing that really convinced the people I talked to into moving, almost all of them liked the other stuff that Ron DeSantis has so prominently brought to Florida, his anti-woke policies, restricting what's said in schools about sexuality and race and systemic racism, his ban on gender-affirming care for trans kids, and on transgender girls doing sports with other girls, his ban on abortion after six weeks. Justina weighs up the trade-offs this way.
虽然新冠政策是真正说服我采访的人搬家的主要因素，但他们几乎所有人都喜欢罗恩·德桑蒂斯在佛罗里达州大力推行的其他政策，比如他的反“觉醒”（anti-woke）政策，限制在学校讨论性倾向、种族和系统性种族主义；禁止为跨性别儿童提供性别肯定护理，禁止跨性别女孩参加女子体育比赛；禁止在怀孕六周后进行堕胎。Justina 是这样衡量取舍的。
I do miss all my family. And I said to myself too, you know, I'd rather be where I have most things in common with people. And I can always visit New Jersey or New York on vacation. [CHUCKLES]
我确实很想念我所有的家人。我也对自己说，你知道，我宁愿和志趣相投的人生活在一起。而且我度假时总能回新泽西州或纽约看看。[轻笑]
For today on our program, Ron DeSantis is running around the country telling Americans we can all have what these new Floridians are loving in their new homes if we vote for him for president. Maybe you've seen the bumper sticker, "Make America Florida."
今天的节目中，罗恩·德桑蒂斯正在全国各地告诉美国人，如果我们投票选他当总统，我们都能拥有这些新佛罗里达人在新家所喜爱的一切。也许你见过那个保险杠贴纸，“让美国变成佛罗里达”（Make America Florida）。
So what would that be like? How's it working out for people? Today, we go inside the Florida experiment he's created there. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
那么那会是什么样子呢？人们的生活过得怎么样？今天，我们深入了解他在那里创建的佛罗里达实验。来自芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，这是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act one, Prescription for Freedom. So Ron DeSantis' governorship, and also the presence of Donald Trump in the state, have created a kind of hothouse of a political experiment on the right in Florida, with all kinds of wealthy influential right-wingers migrating to the state, specifically to Sarasota County, northwest of Mar-a-Lago over on the Gulf Coast.
第一幕，自由处方。罗恩·德桑蒂斯的州长任期，以及唐纳德·特朗普在该州的存在，在佛罗里达州创造了一个右翼政治实验的温床，各种富有的、有影响力的右翼分子迁往该州，特别是迁往海湖庄园西北部的萨拉索塔县（Sarasota County），那边在墨西哥湾沿岸。
Perfect example, Mike Flynn is one of the newest arrivals. He moved to Englewood in Sarasota County. You might remember Mike Flynn. President Trump appointed him as national security advisor, and he lasted only 23 days in that job. He got kicked out after getting in trouble for lying to the FBI about talking to the Russian ambassador.
最好的例子就是，迈克·弗林（Mike Flynn）是最新抵达的人之一。他搬到了萨拉索塔县的恩格尔伍德（Englewood）。你可能还记得迈克·弗林。特朗普总统任命他为国家安全顾问，但他只干了 23 天。在因与俄罗斯大使通话的问题对联邦调查局撒谎而惹上麻烦后，他被解职了。
In Florida, he started a whole new life, waging a kind of information war and a political war on the far right. And Sarasota is the right place for a guy like that to live out his dreams. Steve Bannon, the co-founder of Moms for Liberty, the headquarters of Rumble, of Truth Social-- I could go on-- Charlie Kirk, Patrick Byrne, Doug Logan, they all have ties to Sarasota County. Tucker Carlson is just down the coast.
在佛罗里达州，他开始了全新的生活，在极右翼阵营发动了一场信息战和政治战。萨拉索塔对于这样一个家伙来说，确实是实现梦想的好地方。“自由妈妈”（Moms for Liberty）联合创始人史蒂夫·班农（Steve Bannon）、Rumble 的总部、Truth Social 的总部——我不胜枚举——查理·柯克（Charlie Kirk）、帕特里克·伯恩（Patrick Byrne）、道格·洛根（Doug Logan），他们都与萨拉索塔县有联系。塔克·卡尔森（Tucker Carlson）就在沿岸不远处。
For whatever reason, Sarasota County, which in the past was a wealthy, white area for old-fashioned pro-business Republican types, has now become a place where these MAGA right wing rich guys have set about building their ideal version of society. And at Flynn's side, there's this one guy in particular who's been bounding from one project to the next, creating this little parallel universe down there that we're going to talk about in this next story because this guy's a pioneer in this movement that you're going to be hearing a lot about in this next election. Maybe you've already heard of it, medical freedom.
无论出于什么原因，萨拉索塔县过去是一个老派、亲商业的共和党类型的富裕白人聚居区，现在已经变成了一个让这些 MAGA（让美国再次伟大）右翼富豪们着手建立他们理想社会版本的地方。在弗林身边，有一个特别的人，他不断地从一个项目跳到另一个项目，在那里创造了这个平行宇宙，我们将在下一段故事中谈到，因为这家伙是这场运动的先驱，你们在接下来的选举中会经常听到它。也许你们已经听说过它了：医疗自由。
In Ron DeSantis' case for being president, "Make America Florida," medical freedom is a big item. One of our producers, Zoe Chace, was very interested to understand its appeal and growing popularity, and spent some time down in Sarasota County.
在罗恩·德桑蒂斯的总统竞选诉求“让美国变成佛罗里达”中，医疗自由是一个重大议题。我们的制作人之一佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）非常想了解它的吸引力和日益增长的欢迎度，并在萨拉索塔县待了一段时间。
The guy I'm here to talk about is named Vic Mellor. He has a bunch of money, likes to spend it on politics. Just a few months ago, he paid $3 million for a building in Sarasota County, 959 East Venice Avenue.
我要谈的那个家伙叫维克·梅勒（Vic Mellor）。他很有钱，喜欢把钱花在政治上。就在几个月前，他在萨拉索塔县花了 300 万美元买下了一栋楼，地址是东威尼斯大道 959 号。
And then here's the studio--
然后这是录音室——
He's teaming up with Mike Flynn and some others to use it for this hybrid office down here. One side of it is a production house for the launch of Flynn's upcoming podcast.
他正在和迈克·弗林以及其他人合作，在这里使用这个混合办公空间。其中一侧是弗林即将推出的播客的制作室。
And then here's the studio where General Flynn is going to start his--
然后这是弗林将军即将开始他的——
This is really nice. Like, most people with their little shows, it's not like this. This is a big studio space.
这真的很不错。大多数做这种小节目的人，环境都不像这样。这是一个很大的录音棚空间。
Well, I guess it's good that I have no experience in it, then, huh? So I come out swinging hard.
好吧，那我猜我没经验是件好事，对吧？所以我一上来就会拼尽全力。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Wow.
哇。
Well, what would you expect for General Flynn? He's going to have top of the line-- I'm going to give him top-of-the-line everything, you know?
好吧，你对弗林将军有什么期待呢？他会有顶级的——我会给他提供所有顶级的东西，你知道吗？
Vic is a big guy. He ducks through doors. He's tall. He's wide. He dresses like he just walked off a construction site, which he did. He runs a precast concrete business. He makes the huge blocks of hollowed-out concrete that make up buildings.
维克是个大个子。他弯腰进门，又高又壮。他的穿着就像刚从工地走出来一样，事实也确实如此。他经营着一家预制混凝土公司。他制造那些构成建筑物的大型空心混凝土块。
He dreams big, which brings me to the other half of 959 East Venice, the part I really want to tell you about. The place where Vic and his movement are inventing something new. Specifically, the other half of this building is going to be a medical clinic, We The People Health and Wellness Center. "We the People," drawn in Founding Fathers cursive on the big glass doors. A clinic that caters to people who did not get the COVID vaccine, who do not trust the medical establishment, and want a place to go where they can be treated by people who think like they do.
他梦想远大，这让我想到东威尼斯大道 959 号的另一半，那是我真正想告诉你们的部分。维克和他的运动正在那里发明某种新东西。具体来说，这栋楼的另一半将是一个医疗诊所，“我们人民健康与保健中心”（We The People Health and Wellness Center）。在巨大的玻璃门上用国父们的草书体写着“我们人民”。这是一个专门为那些没有接种新冠疫苗、不信任医疗机构、想要在一个能够被志同道合的人治疗的地方就医的人提供的诊所。
It's about 10,000 square foot. This will be the IV room.
大约 10,000 平方英尺。这将是静脉注射室。
Vic shows me the exam rooms, the carved-out area for pediatrics, the adult examination area, the soft-gray IV-drip room where you can sit quietly and get liquid vitamins pumped into your arms. The whole building is 10,000 square feet. This is roughly half. It opens in September, two to three nurses, maybe a primary care doctor, one pediatrician, for sure, at least to start.
维克向我展示了检查室、专门开辟的儿科区、成人检查区、柔和的灰色静脉点滴室，你可以在那里安静地坐着，让液体维生素输进你的手臂。整栋楼有 10,000 平方英尺。这大约是其中一半。它在九月开业，两到三名护士，可能还有一名初级保健医生，肯定会有一名儿科医生，至少起步阶段是这样。
I wanted to take a look at this building of Vic's because it captures so much to me about this moment in American politics, this half ivermectin clinic, half Mike Flynn flagship podcast studio, it's symbolic of a new momentum on the right, where people took certain lessons from the pandemic-- mandates are bad. Vaccines are suspect. The scientific community is out to get you. The government telling you what to do in health care is dangerous-- and they're building a movement from those principles.
我想看看维克的这栋楼，因为它在我看来捕捉到了美国政治此刻的很多特征，这个一半是伊维菌素（ivermectin）诊所，一半是迈克·弗林旗舰播客录音室的地方，象征着右翼的一种新势头，人们从大流行中吸取了某些教训——强制令是坏的；疫苗值得怀疑；科学界想要针对你；政府告诉你在医疗保健方面该做什么很危险——他们正基于这些原则建立一场运动。
959 East Venice is like an early fort on that frontier, a beachhead for this political movement that's coming into the mainstream called "medical freedom." Also, I'm not going to say this is uniquely Florida, but it's pretty Florida-shaped what happened here. So let me get into Vic's story and the experience of some of these other people in Sarasota to explain how this building came to be.
东威尼斯大道 959 号就像是那个前沿阵地上的一个早期堡垒，是这场名为“医疗自由”并正在进入主流的政治运动的滩头阵地。另外，我不会说这在佛罗里达州是独一无二的，但这里发生的事情很有佛罗里达色彩。所以，让我来深入了解维克的故事以及萨拉索塔其他一些人的经历，来解释这栋楼是如何诞生的。
Vic is a new political convert, and he's newly flush. Vic is not one of the new arrivals in Sarasota County. He's in his early 50s now. He's been here 30 years. He started with nothing and built a successful concrete business. He was a big Fox News watcher with a recent history of bringing new things into the world that he thinks should exist. Like before he built this clinic, a few years ago, feeling antsy and agitated about the state of the world with some money to burn, he decided to buy some land a few miles away from his place in Venice.
维克是一个新的政治皈依者，而且最近刚发了大财。维克不是迁居到萨拉索塔县的新移民之一。他现在 50 多岁出头。他在这一带住了 30 年了。他白手起家，建立了一家成功的混凝土公司。他是个资深的福克斯新闻观众，最近有一种倾向，就是把一些他认为应该存在的新东西带到这个世界上。比如在他建立这个诊所之前，几年前，因为对世界现状感到不安和焦虑，且手头有一些闲钱，他决定在离他位于威尼斯的住处几英里远的地方买了一些地。
And I said, this is what I'm going to do. I am going to open up a campground for kids. It's going to be based on the Constitution with an emphasis on the Second Amendment. So while the kids are out there, we're going to teach them gun safety. And then we're going to bring them out to the range, and they can be proficient, shooting and such, and--
我说，这就是我要做的。我要为孩子们开一个露营地。它将基于宪法，并强调第二修正案。所以当孩子们在那儿时，我们要教他们枪支安全。然后我们要带他们去靶场，他们可以变得熟练，射击之类的，然后——
Teach kids how to shoot?
教孩子如何射击？
Teach kids how to shoot, absolutely. But it's a day camp too. People just go out. I got water slides, and I got all these other little adventure things they do. We got-- there's a big lake with gators, and fish, and zip lines. And we zip line right over the gators. It's--
绝对是教孩子如何射击。但这也是一个日营。人们只是去那里。我有滑水道，还有所有其他他们会玩的那些小冒险项目。我们有——那里有个大湖，里面有短吻鳄和鱼，还有高空滑索。我们就在鳄鱼上方滑索。这是——
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交谈声]
Yeah, absolutely.
是的，绝对是。
He calls it The Hollow because it's a swampy, hollowy place, and after the hollow-core concrete blocks he manufactures. When I was out there, it was like a lost boy paradise, these kind of wild gardens around, bouncing hanging bridges that were stretching over the water between a few islands, grape trellises, flowers, bushes.
他称它为“空洞”（The Hollow），因为它是一个沼泽般的、低洼的地方，也是为了纪念他制造的空心混凝土块。当我到那里时，就像一个失落男孩的乐园，周围有这种野花园、跨越岛屿之间水域的弹跳吊桥、葡萄架、花朵和灌木丛。
There's a gator right there.
那里就有一只鳄鱼。
Where? Ah! Holy--
哪里？啊！天哪——
What, are you scared? That's like a 6 or 7-footer. That's a baby.
怎么了，你怕了吗？那大概只有 6 或 7 英尺长。那只是个婴儿。
After he built The Hollow, Vic met Mike Flynn, which changed his life. And these days, they talk or see each other every day. Vic helps Flynn get all his projects off the ground and helps fund some of them.
在建立了“空洞”之后，维克遇见了迈克·弗林，这改变了他的人生。如今，他们每天都会交谈或见面。维克帮助弗林启动了他所有的项目，并帮助资助其中一些。
I would call Mike Flynn a father figure in Vic's life. He doesn't disagree with that. He grew up without a dad in Woonsocket, Rhode Island. When General Flynn showed up in Sarasota-- that's how Vic always refers to him, as General-- it organized Vic's ambient angst about Trump witch hunts in the media and his jones about the Second Amendment into something much closer to Flynn's worldview, which amounts to a comprehensive One World Order conspiracy aimed at him and other Trump loyalists.
我会称迈克·弗林为维克生命中的父亲形象。他并不否认这一点。他在罗德岛州的文索基特（Woonsocket）长大，没有父亲。当弗林将军出现在萨拉索塔时——维克总是这样称呼他，“将军”——这把他对媒体对特朗普“猎巫”行为的弥漫性焦虑，以及他对第二修正案的渴望，组织成了一种更接近弗林世界观的东西，这归结为针对他和其它特朗普拥护者的“全球主义阴谋”。
Flynn didn't have to push Vic very far. Vic was at January 6. He didn't go into the Capitol building, he says, but he's totally unrepentant about it. He's still convinced the election was stolen from Trump.
弗林不需要推维克太远。维克参加了 1 月 6 日的国会山骚乱。他说他没进国会大厦，但他对此毫无悔意。他仍然确信大选是从特朗普手中窃取的。
OK, so the creation of this clinic at 959 East Venice, it all begins back in 2020, during the pandemic. Vic chafed against the lockdowns and the masks. And lucky for him, he lives in Florida, where the governor, Ron DeSantis, issued an executive order pretty early on in the summer of 2021 that told school districts to stop forcing kids to wear masks in school.
好了，所以东威尼斯大道 959 号这个诊所的创建，始于 2020 年，也就是大流行期间。维克对封锁和口罩感到愤怒。幸运的是，他住在佛罗里达州，州长罗恩·德桑蒂斯在 2021 年夏天很早就发布了一项行政命令，要求学区停止强制孩子们在学校戴口罩。
The school board in Sarasota didn't want to follow the governor's order. They wanted to keep kids in masks. Vic's got two young children in that school district.
萨拉索塔的校董会不想遵循州长的命令。他们想让孩子们继续戴口罩。维克的两个年幼的孩子就在那个学区。
So at that point, all the parents, everyone freaked out. And they made all these groups, and everyone's meeting all over the place, just trying to organize and do whatever. And then someone just said, hey, how about we all just meet at The Hollow? And I was like, OK, bring them all down. Let's do this.
所以在那个时候，所有的家长都吓坏了。他们组建了所有这些团体，每个人都在各处开会，只是试图组织起来做些什么。然后有人说，嘿，我们为什么不就在“空洞”集合呢？我就说，好的，把他们都带过来。让我们这样做。
At this big meeting, Vic meets a very essential partner in this whole endeavor, the other person this story's about, one of the newly politicized moms of Sarasota County. Small but mighty Tanya Parus, petite blonde, pink nail polish, with a bustling just-left-the-PTA-meeting energy. She's got a 5- and a 7-year-old in school.
在这个大型会议上，维克遇到了这场努力中一个非常关键的合作伙伴，也就是这个故事的主角之一，萨拉索塔县新近政治化的一位母亲。个子虽小但充满力量的坦尼娅·帕鲁斯（Tanya Parus），娇小的金发女郎，涂着粉色指甲油，带着那种刚开完家长会、风风火火的劲头。她有两个孩子在学校，分别 5 岁和 7 岁。
I did not want my children to be in masks. They did not want it. My son was breaking out in all these disgusting things, and I have psoriasis. So I was like, oh, my god, what if he's getting-- he's got psoriasis and it's coming out? So I was getting really upset. So I was like--
我不希望我的孩子戴口罩。他们也不想。我儿子的皮肤开始长这些恶心的东西，而且我有牛皮癣。所以我当时就想，天哪，如果他感染了——他有牛皮癣，现在正长出来？我真的变得很心烦。所以我当时就想——
From the mask, you think?
是因为口罩吗，你觉得？
From the mask.
是因为口罩。
Like his skin was drying out somehow?
就像他的皮肤干裂了吗？
Yes.
是的。
OK.
好吧。
And he was not being sanitary with it. He's--
而且他戴得一点都不卫生。他——
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交谈声]
Yeah, exactly. And then now I have a kindergartner coming in who definitely can't wear a mask. I mean, he was flicking them across the room, dropping them on the floor. I saw absolutely no purpose in him wearing it. Drop it on the bathroom floor and then put it on his face, and I'm like, that's absolutely disgusting.
是的，没错。现在我还有一个上幼儿园的孩子，他绝对不能戴口罩。我的意思是，他把口罩在房间里弹来弹去，掉在地板上。我觉得他戴这东西完全没有意义。掉在浴室地板上，然后又贴在脸上，我就想，那绝对是恶心的。
So Vic and a bunch of parents, Tanya among them, decided to organize a big mask waiver signing out at The Hollow, where doctors would give them notes so their kids wouldn't have to wear masks in school. Tanya is a former EMT. She was in a trailer they installed out there taking vitals before they met with the doctors.
所以维克和一群家长，包括坦尼娅在内，决定在“空洞”组织一次大规模的口罩豁免签字活动，医生会给他们开证明，这样他们的孩子在学校就不必戴口罩了。坦尼娅是前急救人员。当时她在那里安置的一辆拖车里，在他们去看医生之前测量生命体征。
And we started it early in the morning, and cars just started coming in, just pouring in, and pouring in, and pouring in. And it's hot. It's freaking hot, and everyone's waiting outside. So I would poke my head out. And I'm like, holy crap. There was-- I mean, there was so many people lined up, I couldn't see the end of the line. And it wrapped all the way around. It was completely full of people.
我们一大早就开始了，车子就开始涌入，涌入，涌入，涌入。天气很热。热死人了，每个人都在外面等。所以我会探出头去看。我就想，天哪。那是——我的意思是，排队的人太多了，我根本看不到队尾。队伍绕了整个一圈。到处都是人。
To be clear, the thing they're all fighting against, wearing masks in school, the science shows masks are effective at slowing the spread of COVID if you wear them. This mask waiver event at The Hollow was a turning point. Once Vic saw how many of them there were, he realized, we could be doing a lot more here. This is a full-fledged political movement that I can throw myself into.
澄清一下，他们都在反对的事情，即在学校戴口罩，科学证明，如果你戴着口罩，口罩在减缓新冠病毒传播方面是有效的。“空洞”的这次口罩豁免活动是一个转折点。一旦维克看到他们有这么多人，他意识到，我们可以做更多的事情。这是一场成熟的政治运动，我可以全身心投入进去。
Tanya, meanwhile, became this connector between these apostate doctors and patients who didn't want to go to regular hospitals. In late 2021 and into the next year, if you wanted a doctor who would see you without a mask or wouldn't push the vaccine, she could give you names.
与此同时，坦尼娅成为了这些“背教”医生和那些不想去正规医院的病人之间的纽带。在 2021 年底到下一年，如果你想要一个不戴口罩见你、或者不会强推疫苗的医生，她可以给你名字。
People talk to each other. They say, hey, Tanya hooked me up with another doctor, whomever.
人们互相交流。他们会说，嘿，坦尼娅给我介绍了一位别的医生，不管是谁。
It's like a whole parallel medical system.
就像一个完全平行的医疗系统。
It felt like a totally underground medical system. And then I did a lot of the vetting for these doctors because they were so busy with patients and dealing with people who needed ivermectin and had COVID.
感觉就像一个完全地下的医疗系统。我做了很多这些医生的背景调查，因为他们太忙了，要看病人，还要应付那些需要伊维菌素并且得了新冠的人。
Getting ivermectin became a huge focus of this emerging parallel medical system. A surprising amount of the emotion driving this movement has to do with ivermectin. You probably remember ivermectin, the horse drug. People started taking huge doses to cure themselves of COVID at one point. But the science says ivermectin doesn't work for COVID. It's an amazing drug for other things like parasites, not COVID.
获得伊维菌素成为了这个新兴平行医疗系统的主要焦点。驱动这场运动的很大一部分情绪竟然与伊维菌素有关。你可能还记得伊维菌素，那种“马药”。人们一度开始服用大剂量的这种药来治愈自己的新冠。但科学表明伊维菌素对新冠无效。它对寄生虫等其他疾病是一种神奇的药物，但对新冠不是。
No matter, though. Doctors on YouTube were promoting things like ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine as miracle cures, quick, cheap, easy solves for COVID. You may remember that YouTube and Twitter and Facebook removed videos because it wasn't true, and it got put on that shortlist of designated official misinformation that the tech companies would actually do something about.
不过，这无关紧要。YouTube 上的医生们在大力宣传伊维菌素和羟氯喹是灵丹妙药，是治疗新冠的快捷、廉价、简易的解决办法。你可能记得 YouTube、Twitter 和 Facebook 删除了这些视频，因为这不是真的，它被列入了那些科技公司确实会采取行动打击的指定“官方错误信息”名单。
But when those ivermectin-loving doctors got shut down, they only got more famous within the medical freedom movement, and set up shop on alternative media platforms like Rumble and Telegram. They created a whole alternate ecosystem of podcasts and podcast networks.
但是，当那些热爱伊维菌素的医生被封杀时，他们反而在这个“医疗自由”运动中变得更加出名，并在 Rumble 和 Telegram 等替代媒体平台上开店。他们创建了一个完整的播客和播客网络替代生态系统。
While he's an amazing person who has been persecuted by the COVID police like no one else. Thank you for joining me, Dr. Eric Nepute. How are you doing?
虽然他是一个了不起的人，但他受到了新冠警察的迫害，这是前所未有的。谢谢你加入我的节目，埃里克·纳普特（Eric Nepute）医生。你好吗？
Dr. McCullough, welcome to my podcast.
麦卡洛（McCullough）医生，欢迎来到我的播客。
Brigade surgeon while serving in the army, Dr. Rashid Buttar.
曾任陆军旅外科医生的拉希德·布塔尔（Rashid Buttar）医生。
Today, we are speaking, yet again, to an eminent expert.
今天，我们要再次采访一位杰出的专家。
The basic conspiracy theory articulated on a lot of these shows is this-- COVID was a man-made created virus masterminded by Bill Gates and the World Health Organization in order to control the world's population. Vaccines were pushed in order to kill us. Lockdowns were used in order to control us. Moderna, Pfizer, they're in on it. They want to kill off ivermectin because it's a cheap alternative to what they're selling.
在这些节目中阐述的基本阴谋论是这样的——新冠病毒是由比尔·盖茨和世界卫生组织一手策划的人造病毒，目的是控制世界人口。推动疫苗是为了杀死我们。封锁是为了控制我们。Moderna、辉瑞，他们都参与其中。他们想消灭伊维菌素，因为它是他们正在销售的药物的廉价替代品。
The conspiracy has a name. It's called The Great Reset. And that's what Flynn will be covering on his show down the hall from the clinic, among other things.
这个阴谋有个名字。它被称为“大重置”（The Great Reset）。这就是弗林会在诊所大厅的另一头在他的节目中讨论的内容，除了一些其他事情。
General Flynn, back to you, sir. What is this vaccination campaign truly all about, for anybody who may be hearing this for the first time?
弗林将军，回到您这里，先生。对于任何可能是第一次听到这个消息的人来说，这次疫苗接种运动到底是为了什么？
What we are facing is, we are facing a globalist takeover of every freedom-loving country in the world, and they're using this vaccination to control us.
我们面临的是，我们正面临每一个热爱自由的国家被全球主义者接管，他们正在利用这种疫苗来控制我们。
When I ask Vic and Tanya straight-up if they believe in the Great Reset, they were both like, I'm not going to cop to that exact thing, like all the stuff you said. Specifically, like, maybe it wasn't Bill Gates. But, yes, there was a power grab, and there was money to be made.
当我直接问维克和坦尼娅他们是否相信“大重置”时，他们都说，我不会承认确切的事情，就像你说的那些。具体来说，也许不是比尔·盖茨。但是，是的，有人在夺权，而且有利可图。
And if you think about that, that doesn't mean that you're a conspiracy theorist. That just means that there's greedy people in the world, which we all know. It doesn't mean that I'm a bad person because I believe our government is more corrupt than you do.
如果你仔细想想，这并不意味着你是一个阴谋论者。这只意味着世界上有贪婪的人，我们都知道这一点。我不因为相信我们的政府比你认为的更腐败，就变成一个坏人。
This is a patriotic movement. It is. I'm going to say, fuck this globalist shit, you know? Seriously. I'm totally against it.
这是一场爱国运动。确实是。我要说，去你的全球主义烂事，你知道吗？严肃点。我完全反对它。
It makes sense to me that Tanya was the person who threw herself into this project of building this alternative medical system, and now running the We The People Clinic at 959 East Venice. She's definitely a take-matters-into-your-own-hands type. And she feels like doctors haven't listened to her in the past when she needed them.
在我看来，坦尼娅是那种投身于建立这个替代医疗系统项目的人，现在又在管理东威尼斯大道 959 号的“我们人民诊所”，这很合理。她绝对是那种“把事情掌握在自己手中”的人。而且她觉得过去当她需要医生时，他们并没有听她的。
I basically have a 21-year-old son, and I have a 9 and a 7. So I had 13 miscarriages in between.
我基本上有一个 21 岁的儿子，还有 9 岁和 7 岁的孩子。所以在这期间我流产了 13 次。
Oh, my god.
天哪。
Yeah. That was-- yeah, that was awful. That was an awful time in my life. But--
是的。那是——是的，那太可怕了。那是我生命中一段可怕的时光。但是——
I'm so sorry. That's very, very hard.
我非常抱歉。这非常、非常困难。
It was awful. So, obviously, and I'm research, research, research, research. That's all I do. What I do is I dig in.
那太可怕了。所以，显然，我一直在研究、研究、研究、研究。这就是我所做的一切。我所做的就是钻研。
You wanted to solve that, figure that out.
你想解决那个问题，搞清楚它。
I like to solve everything, try to at least have an understanding for myself.
我喜欢解决所有事情，至少尝试为自己找到一个理解。
Nine miscarriages in, Tanya seemed to find a doctor who figured out something that might help. And then she had two kids right in a row, the kids who years later would go on to flick masks onto the bathroom floor during COVID.
流产了九次之后，坦尼娅似乎找到了一位医生，想出了一些可能对她有帮助的方法。然后她接连生了两个孩子，也就是几年后在新冠期间把口罩扔在浴室地板上的那两个孩子。
I didn't like that it took me nine miscarriages before anyone cared to figure out what the heck was wrong with me.
我不喜欢流产了九次才有人愿意花心思去弄清楚我到底出了什么问题。
What we're chronicling here, remember, is the establishment of a headquarters of this new MAGA-fied medical freedom movement at 959 East Venice Avenue, half podcast studio, half medical clinic. And the next big moment in the story of the creation of this building happens at arguably the opposite of this place, the main hospital in the area, Sarasota Memorial Hospital.
记住，我们在这里记录的是这场新的 MAGA（让美国再次伟大）化“医疗自由”运动总部的建立，就在东威尼斯大道 959 号，一半是播客录音室，一半是医疗诊所。在这个大楼创建的故事中，下一个重大时刻发生在这个地方的对立面——当地的主要医院，萨拉索塔纪念医院（Sarasota Memorial Hospital）。
Not long after the mask mandate event at The Hollow, Vic started up a political organizing company to support what he calls "freedom candidates," America-first candidates, essentially, Trumpists. He called it The Hollow 2A and threw a lot of money into it. They supported a slate of school board candidates who swept into office. They also backed another group of candidates for a local hospital.
在“空洞”的口罩强制令事件后不久，维克创办了一家政治组织公司，以支持他所说的“自由候选人”，即美国优先候选人，基本上就是特朗普主义者。他称之为“空洞 2A”，并投入了大量资金。他们支持了一批校董会候选人，这些人横扫了选举。他们还支持了另一组当地医院的候选人。
Sarasota Memorial Hospital is governed by a publicly elected board, and they supported four candidates who were aligned with this medical freedom movement. These candidates were basically anti-everything the hospital was doing, anti the CDC protocols they used, anti the vaccines they administered, upset that the hospital didn't offer ivermectin and other alternative medicines to patients who wanted it to treat COVID.
萨拉索塔纪念医院由一个民选委员会管理，他们支持了四名与这场医疗自由运动立场一致的候选人。这些候选人基本上反对医院正在做的一切，反对他们使用的 CDC 规程，反对他们接种的疫苗，对医院没有为想要治疗新冠的病人提供伊维菌素和其他替代药物感到不满。
They kind of wanted to tear the whole place down, and they called for a big investigation into everything that had transpired during COVID. Three of their preferred candidates won, not enough to control the board, enough to make some noise. The public hospital has public meetings every month, and you can imagine how those have been going.
他们简直想把整个地方推倒，他们呼吁对新冠期间发生的一切进行大规模调查。他们支持的三名候选人赢了，虽然不足以控制委员会，但足以制造一些动静。这家公立医院每个月都有公开会议，你可以想象那些会议是怎么进行的。
So let's begin our meeting.
那么，让我们开始我们的会议。
In February of this year, 2023, the board was delivering the results of a three-year review of the hospital's performance during the COVID pandemic. The report was glowing. The hospital's COVID-19 death rate was about 25% lower than state and national averages. Hospital stays were shorter too, which is a pretty great verdict for a place full of elderly people.
今年 2 月，也就是 2023 年，委员会发布了对医院在大流行期间表现的三年评估结果。报告评价很高。医院的新冠死亡率比州和全国平均水平低约 25%。住院时间也更短，对于一个满是老年人的地方来说，这真是一个伟大的裁决。
Vic and The Hollow crew didn't believe those results at all. They started pushing for a completely independent investigation of the hospital's COVID practices. Kind of like those forensic audits that people who thought the election was stolen wanted after 2020. Demands to comb through every ballot, every gear of the voting machines.
维克和“空洞”的那帮人根本不相信这些结果。他们开始推动对医院的新冠实践进行彻底的独立调查。有点像那些认为选举被窃的人在 2020 年之后想要的那些法医审计。要求仔细检查每一张选票，投票机的每一个齿轮。
But this, of course, was way more personal because there was all this grief and pain mixed in with the suspicion.
但这当然更具个人色彩，因为怀疑中夹杂着太多的悲痛和痛苦。
When we had people getting up there crying and saying, all we want to do is, I want answers. I want to sit down with the-- I want to understand why my husband died, why you wouldn't let me come in there, why you wouldn't use ivermectin. Why did you give her remdesivir when I told you not to give her remdesivir? All of these things were coming up.
当我们有人们站在那里哭泣并说，我们想要的只是，我想要答案。我想和——我想明白为什么我丈夫死了，为什么你们不让我进去，为什么你们不用伊维菌素。为什么当我告诉你们不要给她瑞德西韦（remdesivir）时，你们却给她用了瑞德西韦？所有这些事情都冒出来了。
My son was 39 years of age and ended up in the hospital.
我儿子 39 岁，最后进了医院。
"My son was 39 years of age when he went into the hospital," this one woman is saying up at the mic.
“我儿子进医院时 39 岁，”这位女士站在麦克风前说道。
We weren't allowed with him. He was alone. He was alone. And we had a prescription of ivermectin that was very hard to fill. We finally got it filled. We brought it in, and they refused it. And it's like, where is the team anymore? There's no team. It's like, doctors are making the decisions for all of us.
我们不允许陪他。他孤身一人。他孤身一人。我们有伊维菌素的处方，很难配到。我们终于配到了。我们带了进去，他们拒绝了。这就好像，团队在哪里？没有团队。就像是，医生在为我们所有人做决定。
"It's like the doctors are making decisions for all of us."
“就像医生在为我们所有人做决定。”
They said his organs are failing. He's 39. What do you mean his organs are failing? We asked for ivermectin. I had my lawyer on the phone.
他们说他的器官在衰竭。他才 39 岁。你们什么意思说他的器官在衰竭？我们要求伊维菌素。我打电话让我的律师在通话中。
"They said his organs are failing. He's 39. What do you mean his organs are failing? We asked for ivermectin. I had my lawyer on the phone. They refused. All the nurses and doctors," she goes on, "I know how hard you work. But the CDC protocol, it's killing people."
“他们拒绝了。所有的护士和医生，”她继续说，“我知道你们工作有多努力。但 CDC 的规程正在害死人。”
Dr. Manny Gordillo ran the COVID response at the hospital. He was at that hearing, but didn't speak. Ivermectin came up in so much of the testimony that I wanted to talk to him about that. It was a stand-in for so many things, but it was also just a drug, a relatively harmless drug. Why not just give them the ivermectin?
曼尼·戈迪略（Manny Gordillo）医生负责该医院的新冠应对工作。他在那次听证会上，但没有发言。伊维菌素在这么多证词中被提及，我想和他谈谈这个。它是许多事物的代名词，但它也只是一种药，一种相对无害的药。为什么不干脆给他们伊维菌素呢？
So ivermectin, to me, is just a symbol. It's a word. When they did properly done studies, they showed that it is no better than placebo. Large studies, they show no benefit of the thing. So then, how are we going to be-- after the properly done study showed that there is no benefit, how are we going to be telling people, oh, yeah, the thing doesn't work, but I'm still going to give it to you? So we're not in medicine giving people placebo and stuff like that, especially when it distracts from giving the proper medications.
所以对我来说，伊维菌素只是一个符号。它是一个词。当他们进行妥善的研究时，他们表明它并不比安慰剂好。大规模研究表明这种东西没有好处。那么，在我们已经进行了妥善的研究证明它没有好处之后，我们怎么能告诉人们，哦，是的，那东西没用，但我还是要给你用？我们在医学上不会给人们用安慰剂之类的东西，尤其是在它分散了给予适当药物注意力的情况下。
That's what drives him nuts, when people who have been lied to refuse remdesivir, which can work, and want ivermectin, which does not.
这让他抓狂，当那些被欺骗的人拒绝可以起作用的瑞德西韦，却想要不起作用的伊维菌素时。
Which just make no sense. So then it becomes a problem.
这根本没道理。所以这就成了一个问题。
This is the unbridgeable divide between the medical professionals and the medical freedom people in this case. To the activists, it's bad medicine to not give ivermectin. To the professionals, it's bad medicine to give it. There's not a middle ground to be had.
这是医疗专业人员和医疗自由人士在此案中无法逾越的鸿沟。对于活动人士来说，不给伊维菌素是糟糕的医疗手段。对于专业人士来说，给它才是糟糕的医疗手段。没有中间立场可言。
Dr. Gordillo is an infectious disease specialist, and he's had many of these confrontations-- conversations-- with family members demanding alternative COVID treatments over the past few years. It was rough running the hospital's COVID response. He'd coped with death threats against his family, protests outside the ICU. He'd work 100 hours a week. It was hard on his marriage.
戈迪略医生是一位传染病专家，在过去几年里，他与许多要求替代新冠治疗方案的家属有过多次这种对峙——对话。负责医院的新冠应对工作非常艰难。他曾面临对他家人的死亡威胁，ICU 外的抗议。他每周工作 100 小时。这对他婚姻生活影响很大。
His wife was like, these patients hate you, and you're still going to work for them? What kind of a person are you? I thought what happened at the meeting might make him mad.
他妻子当时说，这些病人讨厌你，而你还在为他们工作？你是什么样的人？我以为会议上发生的事情会让他生气。
I mean, I was frustrated more than mad because by that time, I knew what the strategy of these people was. I was mad at the people that did the manipulation. I wasn't mad at the patients. The patients, in the end, they are victims from the manipulators.
我的意思是，比起生气，我更多的是感到沮丧，因为那时我已经知道这些人的策略是什么了。我生那些操纵者的人的气。我不生病人的气。病人在最后是那些操纵者的受害者。
Dr. Gordillo is from Peru, from a place he says the choices were becoming a fisherman or a priest. He tried something else, of course, but he still fishes. That's one of the things he loves about living in Sarasota. Something that surprised me, Dr. Gordillo did take a serious look at ivermectin. There were early studies showing it killed COVID in a test tube. Problem was, the doses it took were much too high to give to a human being.
戈迪略医生来自秘鲁，他说是那个选择要么成为渔夫要么成为牧师的地方。当然，他尝试了别的东西，但他仍然钓鱼。这是他喜欢住在萨拉索塔的原因之一。让我惊讶的一点是，戈迪略医生确实认真研究过伊维菌素。早期的研究表明它在试管中能杀死新冠病毒。问题是，人体所需的剂量太高了，无法给人类使用。
He says, when people know they're going to die, people always ask for alternative treatments to all kinds of things, for HIV, cancer. He's seen it a lot over 30 years. And his attitude is, if the treatment won't hurt you, sure, go get it elsewhere. If an alternative clinic gives out ivermectin, he's like, whatever, they're just not going to do it at his hospital.
他说，当人们知道自己要死时，人们总是要求各种东西的替代疗法，艾滋病、癌症。他在 30 年里见过很多。他的态度是，如果治疗不会伤害你，当然，去别处弄吧。如果一个替代诊所发放伊维菌素，他会说，随便吧，只是他们不会在他的医院里这么做。
I personally don't have a problem with that. If people, in the end, they're going to decide on their own what they want to do, all I can do is give them advice on what is the best treatment as I know it, as our current state of science and the current state of knowledge tells us. And that's the way science goes.
我个人对此没有意见。如果人们最终决定自己想做什么，我所能做的就是根据我所知、根据我们目前的科学状况和知识状况告诉他们什么是最好的治疗方法。这就是科学发展的道路。
I let Tanya and Vic know Gordillo had taken a serious look at ivermectin.
我让坦尼娅和维克知道戈迪略认真研究过伊维菌素。
But when he did look at the studies that were done in America with thousands of people, it showed that basically ivermectin was a placebo. It was like no better than a sugar pill.
但当他查看在美国数千人中进行的研究时，结果显示基本上伊维菌素就是安慰剂。它就像糖丸一样，没有好一点。
Can I answer this one?
我能回答这个吗？
Sure.
当然。
OK, so I would like to see this study that he's referring to, and I would like to see who did it. I'm sure it was cherry-picked because they knew this was coming up anyways.
好的，我想看看他提到的这项研究，我想看看是谁做的。我敢肯定它是精心挑选的，因为他们知道这件事无论如何都会被提出来。
His answer probably shouldn't surprise anyone who's been living in America lately. You have studies? I have studies too. You have doctors? I have doctors that say the opposite.
他的回答可能不会让任何最近住在美国的人感到惊讶。你有研究？我也有研究。你有医生？我有持相反意见的医生。
It's not just him. He's a stand-in for thousands of epidemiologists. Like, is it possible that you guys, for all your best intentions, that you guys aren't properly evaluating scientific studies because you're not doctors?
不仅仅是他。他代表了成千上万的流行病学家。比如，有没有可能，虽然你们出发点是好的，但你们并没有正确评估科学研究，因为你们不是医生？
No, I'm not a doctor. I've taken ivermectin. I know it works. I don't need a doctor to tell me it works. I know it works. I've seen other people take it who were sick-- really sick-- take it, and it works. So if he has the stance that it's still a placebo, then he's an idiot, and he's part of what's wrong with what's going on here.
不，我不是医生。我吃过伊维菌素。我知道它有效。我不需要医生告诉我它是否有效。我知道它有效。我看到其他人病得很重——真的很重——服用了它，它奏效了。所以如果他坚持认为它仍然是安慰剂，那么他就是个白痴，而且他是这里发生错误的一部分。
Also, Zoe, I wanted to add that I've never once said that I was the reviewer of all these clinical studies. These studies that have come out, I've personally spoken with doctors who've been evaluating the studies. And that's where I'm getting my answers from.
另外，佐伊，我想补充一点，我从来没说过我是所有这些临床研究的审评员。这些发布的研究，我亲自和评估过这些研究的医生谈过。这就是我得到答案的地方。
The two sides on this are so divided and both so embattled that the one thing they have in common is how misunderstood each side feels by the other. At that board meeting at Sarasota Memorial Hospital, it was true for Dr. Gordillo. It was true for Tanya.
这两方对此的分歧如此之大，且都如此深陷其中，他们唯一的共同点是双方都觉得对方是多么地误解自己。在萨拉索塔纪念医院的那次董事会会议上，对于戈迪略医生来说是这样。对于坦尼娅来说也是这样。
I don't think you'd understand unless you were on this side of the opinion gateway how shitty they made us feel. Because of what? To me, it's like, why am I-- I just don't believe in mandates. It doesn't mean that I'm a fascist. It doesn't mean--
我想除非你站在观点闸门的这一边，否则你不会明白他们让我们感觉有多糟糕。因为什么？对我来说，就像是，为什么我——我只是不相信强制令。这并不意味着我是法西斯。这并不意味着——
Tanya was like, OK, it's not going to work at Sarasota Memorial.
坦尼娅觉得，好吧，萨拉索塔纪念医院行不通。
The hospital would never surrender.
医院绝不会投降。
The hospital was not going to change?
医院不会改变？
No, they were never even going to offer an apology. So I knew that there was-- we needed a place where people could go and be seen by a doctor, regardless. So let's say another pandemic happens. Are you still comfortable going to see your doctor today? No. Will you be in two years if another pandemic happens? No.
不，他们甚至从未打算道歉。所以我知道——我们需要一个地方，无论如何，人们可以去那里并被医生看诊。所以，假设另一场大流行发生了。你今天还愿意去看你的医生吗？不。如果在两年内另一场大流行发生，你还会去吗？不。
So we still need a place. And that was the whole point with Vic was, I just, more so than anything, told him, we've got to get something. We have to get something up. We have to.
所以我们仍然需要一个地方。这就是维克所关心的核心，我只是，比什么都重要，告诉他，我们必须弄到点东西。我们必须建立起什么东西。我们必须。
After that meeting?
在那次会议之后？
Yeah.
是的。
That's when the Medical Center at 959 East Venice Avenue became a reality. Florida's a great place to do this. Tanya's side is winning in Florida. In September 2021, DeSantis hired this vaccine-skeptical surgeon general to run Florida's response to the COVID pandemic, someone who altered a report's findings to claim the COVID vaccine had more adverse side effects than it actually has.
那时候东威尼斯大道 959 号的医疗中心才成为现实。佛罗里达州是做这件事的好地方。坦尼娅这边在佛罗里达州赢了。2021 年 9 月，德桑蒂斯聘请了一位对疫苗持怀疑态度的外科医生将军来负责佛罗里达州的新冠大流行应对工作，此人篡改了一份报告的结论，声称新冠疫苗的不良副作用比实际情况要多。
DeSantis started publicly questioning the vaccines, saying they could be dangerous, and publicly deriding CDC protocols. This anti-vaccine agenda in Florida arguably had consequences. One study estimated 30,000 extra deaths just in Florida because people didn't get vaccinated.
德桑蒂斯开始公开质疑疫苗，称它们可能很危险，并公开嘲讽 CDC 的规程。佛罗里达州的这种反疫苗议程可以说是有后果的。一项研究估计仅在佛罗里达州就造成了 3 万例额外死亡，因为人们没有接种疫苗。
DeSantis also created this brand-new committee of physicians who would assess any federal health guidelines coming into the state. Dr. Gordillo at Sarasota Memorial Hospital calls this group radical, extremely right wing, outside of mainstream science. The same day he announced that committee, DeSantis filed a petition with the Florida Supreme Court to convene a grand jury, a grand jury to look into things Pfizer and Moderna claimed about the vaccine, which he says were criminally misleading. Dr. Gordillo was like, what is happening?
德桑蒂斯还创建了一个全新的内科医生委员会，他们将评估进入该州的任何联邦健康指南。萨拉索塔纪念医院的戈迪略医生称这个团体为激进、极右翼，背离主流科学。在他宣布那个委员会的同一天，德桑蒂斯向佛罗里达州最高法院提交了一份请愿书，要求召集大陪审团，大陪审团调查辉瑞和 Moderna 关于疫苗的声明，他说这些声明具有严重的误导性。戈迪略医生当时想，发生了什么？
It's just, the whole thing to me is just so politicized. And that upsets me because to see that coming from our governor, that's a little bit too much for me.
对我来说，这一切都太政治化了。这让我感到沮丧，因为看到那是来自我们的州长，对我来说有点过头了。
Yeah, what do you mean, too much for you?
是的，你说的“过头了”是什么意思？
Yeah, I can't take it. It's just-- [LAUGHS] Yeah, it's something that I never thought that it was going to happen in the United States. Maybe if I'm living in North Korea, perhaps, or in China, but not in the US.
是的，我受不了了。这只是——[笑声] 是的，这是我想象中在美国永远不会发生的事情。也许如果我生活在朝鲜，或者在中国，可能，但不是在美国。
In what sense?
在什么意义上？
In the sense that we're telling people-- we're getting a radical view, and do not accept any other points of view, and then push the agenda.
在某种意义上，我们告诉人们——我们正在获得一种激进的观点，并且不接受任何其他观点，然后推行这个议程。
DeSantis is now campaigning for president on his COVID policies, the way he, quote unquote, "fought back the Iron Curtain of Faucism." The language he uses seems designed to appeal to anyone who believes that COVID was a virus created to control us all.
德桑蒂斯现在正以他的新冠政策竞选总统，他是如何，引用他的话说，“击退了福奇主义（Faucism）的铁幕”。他使用的语言似乎旨在吸引任何相信新冠是一种旨在控制我们所有人的病毒的人。
From the very beginning, we refused to let this state descend into some type of Faucian dystopia.
从一开始，我们就拒绝让这个州陷入某种福奇式的反乌托邦。
This is him at CPAC a year ago.
这是他一年前在 CPAC 会议上说的。
In Florida, we reject the biomedical security state which erodes liberty, harms livelihoods, and divides our society. We've stood for freedom across the board, and the result has been, Florida has defeated Faucism. Freedom has prevailed in the Sunshine State.
在佛罗里达州，我们拒绝侵蚀自由、损害生计并分裂我们社会的生物医学安全国家。我们全面维护自由，结果就是，佛罗里达州击败了福奇主义。自由在阳光之州取得了胜利。
Governor DeSantis just signed a set of four medical freedom bills into law two months ago. The press release reads, "Permanent protections for Floridians from the biomedical security state." It not only outlaws any, quote, "discrimination based on vaccine status," it also protects a doctor's right to disagree with what DeSantis has called, "the preferred narrative of the medical community."
德桑蒂斯州长两个月前刚签署了一套四项医疗自由法案。新闻稿写道：“佛罗里达人免受生物医学安全国家侵害的永久保护。”它不仅禁止任何所谓的“基于疫苗状况的歧视”，它还保护了医生不同意德桑蒂斯所称的“医疗界首选叙事”的权利。
The legislation protects doctors from any discipline by state medical boards for spreading wrong information about, say, ivermectin or the vaccine. That's good news for Vic's clinic and any doctors or nurses who choose to work there. DeSantis wants them to keep practicing here in Florida.
该立法保护医生免受州医疗委员会因传播关于——比如——伊维菌素或疫苗的错误信息而进行的任何处罚。这对维克的诊所和任何选择在那里工作的医生或护士来说都是好消息。德桑蒂斯希望他们继续在佛罗里达州执业。
There have been a bunch of other medical freedom-type bills introduced in state legislatures around the country in the past year. And you can see some Republican legislators citing what's happening in Florida as their inspiration. Some of these bills protect doctors who want to promote things like ivermectin for COVID. Florida's law is far and away the most comprehensive. It's the only one that prohibits, quote, "international health organizations"-- the ones Vic and Tanya are so worried about-- "from dictating state policy," for example. Florida stands alone.
过去一年里，全国各地的州议会提出了许多其他医疗自由类型的法案。你可以看到一些共和党议员引用佛罗里达州正在发生的事情作为他们的灵感。其中一些法案保护那些想要为新冠推广伊维菌素等药物的医生。佛罗里达州的法律是目前为止最全面的。它是唯一禁止——比如——“国际卫生组织”——维克和坦尼娅如此担心的那些组织——“支配州政策”的法律。佛罗里达州独树一帜。
As Vic prepares for his clinic's opening in September, he's part of a growing market for anti-vax enthusiasts. The medical freedom movement already has blood banks for the unvaccinated, a whole suite of unvaccinated fertility options, unvaccinated sperm, unvaccinated surrogacy, unvaccinated eggs, unvaccinated breast milk donation.
当维克准备在九月开业诊所时，他也是反疫苗爱好者日益增长的市场的一部分。医疗自由运动已经有了为未接种疫苗者提供的血库、一整套未接种疫苗的生育选择、未接种疫苗的精子、未接种疫苗的代孕、未接种疫苗的卵子、未接种疫苗的母乳捐赠。
Unvaccinated dating apps are a thing. Mike Flynn recently soft-launched an unvaccinated online community called 4thePURE. And Vic, he's already planning an outpatient surgery center next to 959 East Venice. And he says word is getting out about the clinic.
未接种疫苗的交友应用程序也是一种东西。迈克·弗林最近低调推出了一个名为 4thePURE 的未接种疫苗的在线社区。而维克，他已经在计划在东威尼斯大道 959 号旁边建立一个门诊手术中心。他说关于这个诊所的消息正在传开。
My phone is blowing up with people that want to build with the same concept. So--
我的电话响个不停，人们想用同样的理念进行建设。所以——
What do you mean? Say more about that.
这是什么意思？多说一点。
Expansion. This is already-- I only got so much time in my day to do certain things that I'm already doing. So probably in August, I'm going to really entertain expanding into clinics up and down the West Coast of Florida.
扩张。这已经是——我每天只有这么多时间去做我已经在做的事情。所以大概在八月，我会真正考虑向佛罗里达州西海岸上下的诊所扩张。
Really?
真的吗？
Absolutely.
绝对。
But this one isn't even open yet.
但这一个甚至还没开业。
Yeah, but it will be. It's going to be successful.
是的，但它会开的。它会成功的。
When Tanya showed me around the clinic, she pointed to the very front wall. To explain what she wants to put there, she tells me that when she staffed the clinic, she reached out to some of the doctors who'd lost their jobs for what she saw as telling the truth, going against the mainstream. Like the pediatrician she hired, Dr. Renata Moon, she'd been terminated from her practice in Spokane, Washington, she says, for refusing to turn over paperwork showing she was vaccinated against COVID.
当坦尼娅带我参观诊所时，她指着最前面的那面墙。为了解释她想把什么放在那里，她告诉我，当她为诊所配置人员时，她联系了一些因为她眼中的“说真话”、“违背主流”而失去工作的医生。比如她聘请的儿科医生雷纳塔·蒙（Renata Moon）医生，她说她被华盛顿州斯波坎市的诊所解雇了，因为她拒绝上交证明她接种了新冠疫苗的文件。
I really want to take the doctor's letters of termination, and frame them, and put them all along this wall.
我真的很想把医生的解雇信裱起来，挂在这面墙上。
Whoa.
哇。
Because I have probably about 20 or 30 of them that would send them to me. It speaks volumes when you can see, sorry, we're terminating you because you refuse to stop treating with ivermectin.
因为我有大概 20 或 30 封他们寄给我的信。当你能看到“抱歉，我们解雇你，因为你拒绝停止使用伊维菌素治疗”时，这说明了一切。
That's really showing what this place is about.
这真的展示了这个地方是关于什么的。
It's about freedom. It's not ivermectin. It's the point of, the doctors should be able to prescribe whatever they feel the patient could benefit from.
这是关于自由。这不是伊维菌素。重点是，医生应该能够开出他们认为病人能受益的任何药物。
What she's describing is the world DeSantis wants. And Tanya and Vic, they're just living in it, thriving in it. DeSantis wants this for all of America. He's out there selling it. Little problem he's having though, Vic anyway, he'd never go for DeSantis for president. He's a Trump guy.
她描述的是德桑蒂斯想要的世界。而坦尼娅和维克，他们正生活在其中，在其中茁壮成长。德桑蒂斯想把这带给全美国。他正在兜售它。不过他遇到个小问题，至少对维克来说，他永远不会支持德桑蒂斯当总统。他是特朗普的支持者。
Zoe Chace is a producer on our show.
佐伊·蔡斯是我们节目的制作人。
Coming up, you finally figure out what your dream job is, and it more or less gets outlawed by the Florida legislature. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，你终于搞清楚了你的梦想工作是什么，结果它或多或少被佛罗里达州议会禁止了。在一分钟内，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, "The Florida Experiment." Ron DeSantis wants to make America more like Florida. We go for a visit to see what that might be like. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act two, Their Eyes Were Watching Tallahassee.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“佛罗里达实验”。罗恩·德桑蒂斯想让美国变得更像佛罗里达。我们去参观一下，看看那会是什么样子。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，他们的眼睛盯着塔拉哈西（Tallahassee）。
So probably the biggest part of Governor DeSantis' agenda focuses on education. He and Florida Republicans have passed law after law defining what can and cannot be taught in the classroom. And that's not just in elementary and high schools. It's also in universities.
所以德桑蒂斯州长议程中可能最重要的部分集中在教育上。他和佛罗里达州的共和党人通过了一项又一项法律，规定了课堂上能教什么和不能教什么。而且这不仅仅是在小学和高中。这也适用于大学。
This February, Florida Republicans in the statehouse introduced this big bill, HB 999 to limit what you can teach in every public college and university in the state. The earliest versions of the bill were far-reaching. They didn't just ban critical race theory and identity politics from all general education courses. They made it so no student could major or minor in gender studies or in what the bill calls "radical feminist theory," things that have been standard in universities for decades.
今年 2 月，佛罗里达州议会的共和党人提出了这项大法案，HB 999，限制你可以在该州每一所公立学院和大学教什么。该法案的早期版本影响深远。他们不仅在所有通识教育课程中禁止了批判性种族理论和身份政治。他们还规定，任何学生都不得主修或辅修性别研究，或者该法案所称的“激进女性主义理论”，这些几十年来在大学里一直是标准的学科。
For professors who might try to sneak something by, early drafts of the bill didn't explicitly say what would happen to them. But they did say that tenured professors could have their tenure reviewed at any time. Understandably, professors all over the state wondered what this new bill was going to mean in practice.
对于那些可能试图偷偷教点什么的教授，法案的早期草案没有明确说明会发生什么。但他们确实说，终身教授的终身职位可以随时被审查。可以理解，全州的教授们都在想，这项新法案在实践中到底意味着什么。
Emmanuel Dzotsi wondered that too and followed things for one semester between the introduction of the bill and its final passage at one of the biggest universities in Florida, Florida State. He has this story about what it was like for a professor and one of her students.
伊曼纽尔·佐齐（Emmanuel Dzotsi）也对此感到好奇，并在法案提出到最终通过之间的一个学期里，跟踪了佛罗里达州最大的大学之一——佛罗里达州立大学（Florida State University）的情况。他有这个关于一位教授和她的一个学生的故事。
So one of the many students affected by this new law is Kaysin. She's Black, moved to Florida as a kid. She was a freshman this past year. Kaysin's very bright, and not just in the smart and intelligent kind of way. She's a really positive person, very earnest. At a school with more than 30,000 undergrads, she couldn't meet enough of them.
所以受这项新法律影响的众多学生之一是凯辛（Kaysin）。她是黑人，小时候搬到了佛罗里达州。去年她是新生。凯辛非常聪明，而且不仅仅是那种机灵和智能意义上的。她是一个非常积极、非常真诚的人。在一所拥有超过 3 万名本科生的学校里，她见不完这么多人。
I will start talking to people if we just happen to be passing each other and I notice something. Like, oh, my gosh, your hair looks so cute.
如果我们刚好擦肩而过，我注意到什么，我就会开始和人聊天。比如，哦，我的天，你的头发看起来真可爱。
Wow. You're a compliment queen.
哇。你真是个“赞美女王”。
[LAUGHS] Yes, that's probably a good way to put it. I meet a lot of people that way.
[笑声] 是的，这可能是一个好的说法。我就是那样认识很多人的。
Kaysin was also super passionate about the academic side of things. She chose Florida State, in part, because she got a scholarship, and she was aiming to be the first person in her family to get a bachelor's degree. Her focus was to do something that would get her a job, so she looked into picking up a major in entrepreneurship, which would give her the tools to start her own business.
凯辛对学术方面也充满热情。她选择佛罗里达州立大学的部分原因是她获得了奖学金，而且她的目标是成为家里第一个获得学士学位的人。她的重点是做一些能让她找到工作的事情，所以她研究了修读创业专业，这将给她提供开创自己企业的工具。
But then she signed up for this African-American studies class, just, you know, to try it, which, as any disappointed parent of a business major who drops it all for a life in humanities can tell you, this is how it starts. Kaysin loved the course, couldn't ask enough questions of her professor.
但后来她注册了这门非裔美国人研究课程，只是，你知道，试一试，这正如任何一个对放弃一切去投身人文科学而感到失望的商科学生家长可以告诉你的那样，这就是开始。凯辛喜欢这门课程，对她的教授问不够问题。
I lost my mind. I entered a fervor. Because I knew I could not ask him every single question I wanted to in the middle of class, I would literally write down every single one of my thoughts. And then after class, I would literally follow him out of the building. We would just talk for as he's walking to his car from the classroom.
我简直疯了。我进入了一种狂热状态。因为我知道我不能在课间问他我想问的每一个问题，我简直会写下我所有的想法。然后下课后，我会跟着他走出大楼。就在他从教室走到车边的路上，我们只是在交谈。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So this man is trying to leave, and you're just like, could you--
所以这个人正试图离开，你就像是，你能——
Yes. I would just be talking to him and asking him more and more questions about what he thought about different things.
是的。我只是会和他说话，并问他更多关于他对自己所想的不同事物的看法。
Kaysin loved the class so much that by the end of the semester, she switched her major to English and added a minor in African-American studies. She wanted to dive deeper on Black writers from her state, from Florida. So for her second semester, she signed up for a class on Southern Black literature, the Literatures and Cultures of the Afro Gulf South, taught by a Black female professor named Dr. Alisha Gaines. And when Kaysin met Dr. Gaines on the first day of class, she was obsessed with her.
凯辛非常喜欢这门课，到学期结束时，她把专业换成了英语，并增加了非裔美国人研究辅修。她想深入研究她所在州——佛罗里达州——的黑人作家。所以第二个学期，她注册了一门关于南方黑人文学的课，即“非裔海湾南方文学与文化”，由一位名叫艾丽莎·盖恩斯（Alisha Gaines）博士的黑人女教授授课。当凯辛第一天上课见到盖恩斯博士时，她就被她迷住了。
I thought she was so cool. [LAUGHS] She just arrived into class with this kind of warm confidence. I remember noticing that she was wearing what I would say is kind of almost this fancy black dress, but then was wearing sneakers with it.
我觉得她太酷了。[笑声] 她带着一种温暖的自信走进教室。我记得注意到她穿的是那种我称之为几乎是华丽的黑色连衣裙，但脚下穿的是运动鞋。
The sneakers got you?
运动鞋打动了你？
I don't know. It was my first time having a Black professor in college, a Black female professor in college. And it was just-- it was like I was able to look at her and think to myself, I could be like that someday. That's something I could be.
我不知道。这是我第一次在大学里有一位黑人教授，一位黑人女教授。这就像——我能够看着她并心想，总有一天我也能像那样。那是我可以成为的样子。
Within a few weeks of meeting Dr. Gaines, Kaysin decided she was going to become just like her, become a professor of African-American literature. But right as she figured out what she wanted to do with her life, HB 999 was introduced. It was late February, a few weeks into the semester.
遇见盖恩斯博士几周后，凯辛决定她要变得像她一样，成为一名非裔美国文学教授。但就在她弄清楚了自己想做什么时，HB 999 法案被提出了。那是 2 月下旬，学期进行了几周。
I think that I first saw it on Instagram. And I read over it. And I thought to myself, well, that can't be true. That's insane.
我想我第一次是在 Instagram 上看到的。我读了一遍。我心想，这不可能是真的。这太疯狂了。
Kaysin realized that a lot of the things that she loved most about Gaines' class might be affected by this bill. The class was, of course, about literature. But it also involved discussions about the cultural and political context for each book. For example, at one point, they read a novel about one family's experience of Hurricane Katrina, and they talked about the role systemic racism played in the government's response to it.
凯辛意识到，她最喜欢盖恩斯课程的许多地方可能会受到这项法案的影响。这门课当然是关于文学的。但它也涉及关于每本书的文化和政治背景的讨论。例如，有一次，他们读了一本关于一个家庭经历卡特里娜飓风的小说，他们谈论了系统性种族主义在政府应对中的作用。
It felt like without those sorts of discussions, Literatures and Cultures of the Afro Gulf South just wasn't Literatures and Cultures of the Afro Gulf South. And she felt like her entire field of study, Black literature, specifically Black literature that probed the true legacy of what it means to be Black in America, the thing she had just realized she wanted to make her life's work, was under threat.
感觉如果没有那些讨论，“非裔海湾南方文学与文化”就不再是“非裔海湾南方文学与文化”了。她觉得她整个研究领域，即黑人文学，特别是那些探究作为美国黑人真正意味着什么的黑人文学，也就是她刚刚意识到她想作为毕生事业去做的事情，正受到威胁。
Like, there was one day where they were discussing Their Eyes Were Watching God in class, and Kaysin just couldn't stop thinking about the bill.
就像，有一天他们在课堂上讨论《他们的眼睛望着上帝》（Their Eyes Were Watching God），凯辛就是无法停止思考这项法案。
I was just thinking about, what if no one else ever gets to even read this in a class again? What if no one gets to have these kind of discussions that we're having again?
我只是在想，如果以后再也没有人能在课堂上读到这个怎么办？如果以后再也没有人能像我们这样讨论怎么办？
Kaysin wondered how seriously she should take the bill. It was something I was wondering about too. I thought, this bill is just a draft. Surely a lot of this sweeping language targeting subjects, that was going to come out, right? And even if it didn't and the bill passed, it's such an attack on free speech, surely it wouldn't hold up in court.
凯辛想知道她应该多认真地对待这项法案。这也是我一直在想的。我想，这项法案只是个草案。肯定很多这种针对学科的宽泛语言会被删掉，对吧？即使没有被删掉且法案通过了，这也是对言论自由的攻击，肯定在法庭上站不住脚。
But pretty much every one of the professors who talked to me at FSU said that the bill's very introduction had a chilling effect. The language in the bill was so broad, it was hard to pin down exactly what would be prohibited. Professors told me that they and their colleagues were feeling pressured to change things about their work, regardless of what happened with the law. And Dr. Gaines says, that didn't seem like an accident.
但几乎每一个和我谈过的佛罗里达州立大学的教授都说，该法案的提出本身就产生了“寒蝉效应”。法案中的语言如此宽泛，很难确定到底什么会被禁止。教授们告诉我，无论法律最后如何，他们和他们的同事都感到有压力要改变他们的工作内容。盖恩斯博士说，这看起来不像是个意外。
Some of the early versions of this legislation is so ridiculous and outlandish. And you realize, it's written to chill. It's written to put us on notice.
这项立法的一些早期版本是如此荒谬和古怪。你意识到，它是为了制造寒蝉效应而写的。它是为了让我们收到通知而写的。
But even believing that, it was hard to know what to do. Like, the same week the bill was introduced, Dr. Gaines got word that she was going to be teaching a course she hadn't taught before in the fall, Major Figures in American Literature, which is a really broad subject, right? In theory, you could teach any assortment of great American authors. And Dr. Gaines was considering making the focus of the class the authors of the Harlem Renaissance.
但即使相信这一点，也很难知道该怎么办。就像法案提出的同一周，盖恩斯博士接到通知，她秋季要教一门她以前没教过的课程：“美国文学中的主要人物”，这真是一个宽泛的主题，对吧？理论上，你可以教任何伟大的美国作家组合。盖恩斯博士正在考虑将课程重点放在哈莱姆文艺复兴时期的作家身上。
The authors that I would want to talk with students about are major American authors, but they're also Black. So can I just teach Black folks, and people will be fine with that? Or are they wanting Whitman? Or are they wanting Faulkner?
我想和学生讨论的作家是主要的美国作家，但他们也是黑人。所以我能只教黑人吗，大家会觉得没问题吗？还是他们想要惠特曼（Whitman）？或者是他们想要福克纳（Faulkner）？
Gaines wondered, with HB 999 and all of the discourse around education in the state, if she could teach the historical racial context around an era like the Harlem Renaissance and its continued relevance today in a class where some students would just be there to fulfill a writing requirement.
盖恩斯想，在 HB 999 法案和该州关于教育的所有讨论下，她是否能在这样一个班级里教授像哈莱姆文艺复兴时期这样的历史背景及其今天持续的相关性，而班里有些学生只是为了满足写作要求才来上课。
She would encounter students from all different kinds of majors, students who might not necessarily be trying to learn about Black writers, and who would be able to record her classes and report her.
她会遇到来自各种各样专业的学生，有些学生可能不一定试图学习黑人作家，而且他们能录下她的课并举报她。
Is there going to be a student in my class taking it just to be controversial, just to be difficult? That kind of stuff you don't want to keep at the forefront of your brain when you're trying to interact with students, and learn with them, and engage the material. But you have to think about it a little bit. And then it creates a little bit of a, can I-- can I fully trust this classroom? Can I fully trust all my students?
会不会有一个学生为了争议、为了制造困难来选我的课？当你试图和学生互动、学习、参与材料时，你不想把那种东西放在大脑的前沿。但你不得不考虑一点。然后这创造了一种，我可以——我可以完全信任这个教室吗？我可以完全信任我所有的学生吗？
In March, I heard about something that was adding to the sense of dread so many people I talked to were feeling. It was a list that was getting passed around, and on it were 34 classes at FSU. Most of the professors I talked to about it didn't know exactly what it meant to be on the list, but they figured it wasn't a good thing.
三月，我听说了一些事情，这增加了许多和我谈过的人感到的恐惧感。那是一份被传阅的清单，上面有佛罗里达州立大学的 34 门课程。大多数和我讨论过它的教授不知道被列入清单到底意味着什么，但他们觉得这不是什么好事。
At first, it wasn't exactly clear who created the list. The DeSantis administration? The university?
起初，还不清楚是谁创建了这份清单。德桑蒂斯政府？还是大学？
So the first class on the list is--
所以清单上的第一门课是——
Dr. Gaines and I looked through the list. There are programs and classes you'd expect to see, courses that talk about race and gender in ways that might concern Republicans on an anti-woke crusade, like AMH 2096, Black Women in America, or SYD 3800, Sociology of Sex and Gender.
盖恩斯博士和我查看了这份清单。有你预料中会看到的项目和课程，那些以共和党人在“反觉醒”十字军东征中可能关心的那种方式讨论种族和性别的课程，比如 AMH 2096，“美国的黑人女性”，或 SYD 3800，“性别社会学”。
But there are many classes missing. Dr. Gaines' class that Kaysin was in, Literatures and Cultures of the Afro Gulf South, wasn't on there, which made no sense, not that she was complaining.
但有很多课程没在上面。凯辛上过的那门盖恩斯博士的“非裔海湾南方文学与文化”没在上面，这毫无道理，不是说她在抱怨。
That-- excuse me-- legislators, that is an exhaustive list of all the courses that you need to worry about. Thank you. Complete list, don't look any further.
那个——抱歉——立法者们，那是你们需要担心的所有课程的详尽列表。谢谢。完整的列表，不要再看了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You also had a lot of classes that didn't seem to fit, like Classical Perspectives on Dance, Masterpieces of German Literature. After looking into it, I figured out that the university made the list. The DeSantis administration had requested all public universities send in a comprehensive list of anything on campus related to diversity and inclusion and critical race theory.
你还有很多看起来并不合适的课程，比如“舞蹈的古典视角”、“德国文学名著”。深入调查后，我发现是大学制作了这份清单。德桑蒂斯政府要求所有公立大学提交一份校园内关于多元化、包容性和批判性种族理论的所有东西的详尽清单。
I couldn't get anyone at the school to explain to me why this oddly random list of courses was what they decided to send in. Was it some Machiavellian mind game? Was it incompetence? Who knows? But this disembodied list being passed around, it had an effect. It added to the web of self-doubt and fear that professors at FSU were feeling.
学校里没有人能向我解释为什么这份奇怪的随机课程列表是他们决定提交的东西。这是一场马基雅维利式的心理游戏吗？是无能吗？谁知道呢？但这份被传阅的游离清单确实产生了影响。它增加了佛罗里达州立大学教授们感受到的自我怀疑和恐惧的网络。
Some of them were already changing their courses, trying to make them hold up to scrutiny. I talked to one professor who removed work by Ibram Kendi from his syllabus and emphasized empirical studies about traffic stops and hiring discrimination instead.
他们中有些人已经在改变课程，试图让它们经得起审查。我和一位教授谈过，他从教学大纲中删除了伊布拉姆·肯迪（Ibram Kendi）的作品，并强调了关于交通拦截和招聘歧视的实证研究。
Two other professors took the understandable step of changing the names of their courses, basically erasing the giant targets they had on their backs. A class called "Critical Race Theory" will now be listed as "The Sociology of Race and Ethnicity." Another class, "Feminism and Travel," you can find out under the new name, "Journeys in Women's Literature." Both courses are, content-wise, basically the same as they were before.
另外两名教授采取了可以理解的步骤，改变了课程名称，基本上擦掉了他们背上的巨大靶子。一门名为“批判性种族理论”的课程现在将被列为“种族与族裔社会学”。另一门课程，“女性主义与旅行”，你可以在新名字“女性文学中的旅程”下找到它。内容上，这两门课程与以前基本相同。
We are already self-censoring. And, in fact, I pulled critical race theory out of my self-description on my faculty web page.
我们已经在自我审查了。事实上，我从我教师网页的自我描述中删除了批判性种族理论。
That's Dr. Celia Caputi, one of Dr. Gaines' colleagues in the English department. She teaches classes about women's literature. And the subjects targeted in the legislation were so open to interpretation with no explanation of what the punishment would be that she honestly couldn't figure out what she should be teaching.
那是西莉亚·卡普蒂（Celia Caputi）博士，盖恩斯博士在英语系的同事。她教授关于女性文学的课程。立法中针对的主题非常容易被解读，且没有解释惩罚会是什么，以至于她真的不知道她应该教什么。
Feminist theory and gender studies were baked into her courses. She worried about losing her tenure and getting fired. And so she spent an enormous amount of time this past semester trying to do whatever she could to protect herself.
女性主义理论和性别研究融入了她的课程。她担心失去终身职位并被解雇。所以她在过去一个学期里花了大量时间试图尽一切努力保护自己。
I had started writing a new article just about a week ago. And now I look at the first page, and I was really proud. I wrote down-- I wrote the introduction up. I had written a lot of notes, but I finally sat down at the computer and wrote up the introduction. And, well, guess what. It references a concept called the "lesbian continuum" in the second paragraph.
我大约一周前刚开始写一篇文章。现在我看着第一页，我真的感到自豪。我写下——我写了介绍。我写了很多笔记，但我终于坐到电脑前写了介绍。而且，嗯，猜猜看。它在第二段提到了一个叫“女同性恋连续体”（lesbian continuum）的概念。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What's the lesbian continuum?
什么是女同性恋连续体？
OK, the lesbian continuum is a concept here-- we're talking feminist theory, uh-oh! The F word, that terrible thing-- the lesbian continuum is a concept put forth by lesbian feminist poet Adrienne Rich. And her theory is that in a patriarchal heterosexist culture where women are fully responsible for caring for infants, every child, every infant's first love is his or her mother. And so that for women, the initial disposition is same-sex love, and that heterosexist culture forces a woman to realign herself. And--
好的，女同性恋连续体是一个概念，这里——我们谈论的是女性主义理论，噢噢！F 开头的词，那可怕的东西——女同性恋连续体是女同性恋女性主义诗人阿德里安娜·里奇（Adrienne Rich）提出的一个概念。她的理论是，在家长制异性恋中心主义文化中，女性完全负责照顾婴儿，每个孩子、每个婴儿的初恋都是他或她的母亲。所以对于女性来说，最初的倾向是同性之爱，而异性恋中心主义文化迫使女性重新调整自己。而且——
In other words, if you're a Florida Republican who believes that radical liberal professors are turning students gay, this article would be a red flag.
换句话说，如果你是一个佛罗里达州的共和党人，相信激进的自由派教授正在把学生变成同性恋，这篇文章会是一个危险信号。
You see now how this puts me in this situation?
你现在看到这让我处于这种境地了吗？
Yeah. [LAUGHS] I see now how you're in it, yeah.
是的。[笑声] 我现在看到你是怎么处于其中的了，是的。
Yeah, everything I want to do, everything I can get excited about, makes me feel insecure at the same time. Is this going to make me or break me?
是的，我想做的每一件事，我能感到兴奋的每一件事，同时又让我感到不安。这会成就我还是毁了我？
The chilling effect is a lie.
“寒蝉效应”是个谎言。
This is one of the people who wrote HB 999, State Representative Alex Andrade. He'd been hearing about this chilling effect from so many critics of the bill. He was defensive when asked about it at first, about his intent, very angry that people thought he and the bill were racist, which he denies.
这是 HB 999 的起草者之一，州众议员亚历克斯·安德拉德（Alex Andrade）。他从该法案的许多批评者那里听到了关于这种寒蝉效应的说法。起初被问及他的意图时，他显得很防御，非常愤怒人们认为他和这项法案是种族主义的，他对此予以否认。
He says the fear that greeted HB 999 was inflamed by Democrats and the media. When I said that professors were feeling like they needed to change their courses, he was like, good. Maybe they need to.
他说，迎接 HB 999 的恐惧是被民主党人和媒体煽动起来的。当我说教授们感觉需要改变课程时，他说，很好。也许他们需要这样做。
The whole purpose of the bill is to, if you're going to make an argument, tie it to fact. Tie it to evidence. And if you want to still teach a conclusion without evidence, higher education institutions in the state of Florida may not be for you.
法案的全部目的是，如果你要提出一个论点，请将其与事实挂钩。将其与证据挂钩。如果你仍然想在没有证据的情况下教一个结论，佛罗里达州的高等教育机构可能不适合你。
Here's the thing. Andrade doesn't believe that systemic racism is inherent to the institutions of the United States today, even though a whole host of academic work says it is. He says, it's important that people learn about the systemic racism of the past. Learn about Jim Crow, for example. But that's the past, he says. If there's an institution that's racist right now, he said to me, I'll fight it with you.
重点是。安德拉德不相信系统性种族主义在今天的美国制度中是固有的，尽管大量的学术著作都这么说。他说，人们了解过去系统性种族主义很重要。例如，了解吉姆·克劳法。但他说是过去的事了。他说，如果现在有一个种族主义机构，他会对我说，我会和你一起斗争。
Tell me what institution is racist.
告诉我哪个机构是种族主义的。
Our justice system, it is inherently unequal and does disproportionately affect Black men. And there is a direct line between high rates of incarceration and policing that is tied to possible implicit racial bias. I think that's pretty cut and dry.
我们的司法系统，它本质上是不平等的，确实不成比例地影响着黑人男性。在极高的监禁率和警务之间有一条直接的线，这与可能的隐含种族偏见有关。我认为那相当清楚。
Well, no, there's no question that there have been instances. What I've just told you is that if you point me to an institution that is intentionally being racist today, I will fight it with you.
嗯，不，毫无疑问确实存在过例子。我刚才告诉你的是，如果你指出一个今天正在蓄意种族主义的机构，我会和你一起斗争。
OK, that's great.
好的，那太棒了。
I hope you're noticing the distinction Andrade is making here. He's saying, there are isolated instances of, say, Black men being arrested because they're Black. But that's not proof of institutional racism.
我希望你注意到安德拉德在这里做出的区别。他是在说，有孤立的例子，比如黑人男性因为是黑人而被捕。但这并不能证明制度性种族主义。
There's no evidence. If you can't point to me what institution is racist today.
没有证据。如果你不能指出今天哪个机构是种族主义的。
Yeah, I mean, I have. But let's move on here because I have other questions, and I want you to be aware of your time.
是的，我是说，我已经指出过了。但我们继续吧，因为我还有其他问题，我想让你注意你的时间。
Whoa, Emmanuel, Emmanuel.
哇，伊曼纽尔，伊曼纽尔。
I have. Come on, mate.
我已经指出过了。来吧，伙计。
No, you haven't.
不，你没有。
I don't know. I would disagree with that. And a big part of teaching also is just acknowledging where the weight of the scholarship is. And if the weight of the scholarship, which it does, says that a lot of our systems in this country are inherently unequal because initially they were not necessarily built to serve everybody, that just kind of is what it is.
我不知道。我不同意这一点。教学的一大部分也只是承认学术研究的分量在哪里。如果学术研究的分量——确实如此——说这个国家的很多系统本质上是不平等的，因为最初它们不一定是为了服务每个人而建立的，那也就那样了。
There's no disagreement that Jim Crow laws were racist, that are evidence of systemic racism. However, if anyone is saying today, currently our institutions are inherently racist--
毫无疑问，吉姆·克劳法是种族主义的，那是系统性种族主义的证据。然而，如果今天有人说，我们目前的制度本质上是种族主义的——
Yeah, that's where you would disagree.
是的，那是你会不同意的地方。
Because it's just false.
因为它只是假的。
Right, well, we're disagreeing. I don't think it's false. I know it's not. But thank you for sharing that.
好吧，我们正在分歧。我不认为它是假的。我知道它不是。但谢谢你的分享。
He did this a few times. Presented with the weight of the evidence, he'd just say, there's no evidence, or he'd mention a study that he'd seen. And this is what's making life for professors so hard. They do already present clear and fact-based evidence.
他这样做过几次。面对证据的分量，他只会说，没有证据，或者提到他见过的一项研究。这就是让教授们的生活变得如此艰难的原因。他们确实已经提出了清晰且基于事实的证据。
But Andrade is telling them they can't state what their evidence adds up to if it's a conclusion he and the Republican legislature don't agree with. How do you navigate that? As one professor told me, we can't just get up there and be like, so there's these discrepancies in health outcomes, but I can't tell you why. That's just not teaching.
但安德拉德告诉他们，如果这是一个他和共和党立法机构不同意的结论，他们就不能陈述他们的证据加起来意味着什么。你怎么应对那个？正如一位教授告诉我的，我们不能只是站在那里像是，所以健康结果有这些差异，但我不能告诉你为什么。那根本不是教学。
I reached out to the DeSantis administration to ask them about HB 999. They didn't directly respond to my questions. Instead, their press secretary sent me links to a DeSantis press conference and a couple of other public statements about the bill. And the message from those was pretty clear. If you want to teach stuff about critical race theory or gender ideology, we're not going to be funding it. Go somewhere else.
我联系了德桑蒂斯政府询问他们关于 HB 999 的事。他们没有直接回答我的问题。相反，他们的发言人给我发了德桑蒂斯新闻发布会的链接以及关于该法案的其他几个公开声明。那些声明传达的信息非常明确。如果你想教关于批判性种族理论或性别意识形态的东西，我们不会资助。去别的地方吧。
Dr. Gaines said that professors heard that message loud and clear. Students did too. Kaysin, for sure, she was following the news about the bill.
盖恩斯博士说教授们清清楚楚地听到了那个信息。学生们也是。凯辛当然也是，她一直在关注关于该法案的新闻。
She came up and approached me at the end of my class. And she was just very upset. She said, what are you going to do about it?
下课后她走过来接近我。她非常难过。她说，你要怎么做？
What did she mean by that?
她是什么意思？
I think she meant, are you going to curtail what you have to say or what we're going to read or teach? Are you going to roll over?
我想她是说，你是要缩减你要说的话，或者我们要阅读或教授的东西吗？你要屈服吗？
Kaysin said she actually meant something a little different.
凯辛说她实际上指的意思有一点点不同。
I wanted to know how she was handling it because I kind of wanted to know how I should handle it, almost.
我想知道她是怎么处理它的，因为我有点想知道我应该怎么处理它。
Oh, you were like, I need to ask her how she's handling it so I can know how seriously I should be taking this, how afraid I should be?
噢，你是说，我需要问她是怎么处理的，以便我知道我应该多严肃地对待这件事，我应该多害怕？
Yeah.
是的。
Dr. Gaines told Kaysin she wasn't going to change her class at all, but she'd been feeling the pressure. A few weeks earlier, she decided to show a documentary in both of the classes she was teaching that semester.
盖恩斯博士告诉凯辛她根本不会改变她的课程，但她一直感到压力。几周前，她决定在那学期她教的两门课中都放映一部纪录片。
The documentary was called Invisible History, Middle Florida's Hidden Roots, and it was a documentary about the legacy of slavery around Leon County, where FSU is located. The first class she showed it to was all grad students. And when the film was finished, there was this stunned silence in the room.
这部纪录片叫《隐形历史：佛罗里达中部的隐藏根源》（Invisible History, Middle Florida's Hidden Roots），是关于利昂县（Leon County，佛罗里达州立大学所在地）奴隶制遗留问题的纪录片。她放给研究生上的第一堂课，当电影放完时，房间里是一片震惊的寂静。
One of my graduate students said, well, DeSantis didn't want us to see that.
我的一位研究生说，好吧，德桑蒂斯不想让我们看那个。
As in, Dr. Gaines, you just did something that could get you in trouble. Dr. Gaines was surprised. This was just a fact-based documentary that had been made by a filmmaker in residence at FSU, though it is pretty unflinching in the way it ties Leon County's Jim Crow past with its present.
意思是，盖恩斯博士，你刚才做了一件可能会让你惹上麻烦的事。盖恩斯博士很惊讶。这只是一部基于事实的纪录片，由佛罗里达州立大学的一位驻校电影制作人制作，尽管它在将利昂县的吉姆·克劳过去与现在联系起来的方式上相当直白。
Half an hour later, she screened the same documentary for Kaysin's class. And they were in the middle of a film when she noticed something.
半小时后，她为凯辛的班级放映了同一部纪录片。当他们正看到电影中间时，她注意到了什么。
I think the documentary was about-- had gotten to a point about lynching. So it was a very heavy moment. I'm not going to say it wasn't. That history is hard. That's painful. And that history is right here in Leon County itself. And there was a moment where a student walked out of the classroom while it was screening. I literally kind of jumped in my seat because I wasn't sure why he was leaving.
我想纪录片是关于——已经到了关于私刑的一点。所以那是一个非常沉重的时刻。我不会说它不是。那段历史很沉重。那是痛苦的。而且那段历史就在利昂县本身。有一个瞬间，一名学生在放映时走出了教室。我简直在座位上跳了一下，因为我不确定他为什么离开。
Dr. Gaines started panicking.
盖恩斯博士开始恐慌。
I was immediately thinking, is he walking out because he's protesting what I'm screening? Is he walking out because he is made so very uncomfortable by this documentary about slavery in Leon County or Middle Florida? All of these things are kind of racing through my head.
我立刻在想，他走出去是因为抗议我放映的东西吗？他走出去是因为这部关于利昂县或佛罗里达中部奴隶制的纪录片让他感到如此不舒服吗？所有这些事情在我的脑海中奔腾。
Gaines wasn't sure what would happen if she had offended his kid. So she wrote down some notes about where exactly in the film he'd walked out and then sat there, anxiously looking at the other students to see if anyone else was going to follow. And then--
盖恩斯不确定如果她冒犯了他的孩子会发生什么。所以她写下了一些关于他在电影中确切哪里走出的笔记，然后坐在那里，焦虑地看着其他学生，看看是否还有人会跟随。然后——
That student came back a few minutes later. He had just gone to the restroom. And so I'm having this, [GASPS] oh, gosh. He was just using the restroom.
那名学生几分钟后回来了。他只是去了洗手间。所以我经历了那个，[喘气] 噢，天哪。他只是用了个洗手间。
I checked with the student, and he hadn't actually gone to the bathroom. He stepped into the hall because of some news he'd gotten. But Dr. Gaines was seeing threats where there weren't any. She was beginning to doubt herself.
我向学生核实了，他其实并没有去洗手间。他走到大厅是因为他接到的一些消息。但盖恩斯博士看到了不存在的威胁。她开始怀疑自己。
It's that double think that I have never had to do in a classroom in my entire career.
那种双重思维（double think）是我整个职业生涯中在课堂上从未不得不做过的。
By early April, as the bill was being debated in committee, Kaysin was finding it increasingly difficult to stay upbeat as she saw news about the bill's progress. It had been a rough semester.
到 4 月初，当法案在委员会中被辩论时，凯辛发现，随着她看到关于法案进展的新闻，她越来越难以保持乐观。那是一个艰难的学期。
I was trying my best to enjoy it, even though there was a kind of constant backdrop of stress with everything happening. And I thought about dropping out of college.
我尽力享受它，尽管所有发生的事情都有持续的压力背景。我想过退学。
Wait, wait, wait.
等等，等等，等等。
Yeah, it ran through my head several times. Even though I enjoyed it, even though I was so focused on getting to class, in my head, several times, I was like, maybe I should just bail out.
是的，这在我脑海中闪过几次。尽管我很享受，尽管我很专注于上课，但在我脑海中，几次我都想，也许我应该直接放弃。
It's kind of like if someone gives you a beautiful present, like they give you a beautiful watch. And they say, hey, I might take this away at any second. And when I take it away, I'm just straight up going to mug you. Would you accept the watch? Would you want to wear it on your wrist, so that after it's gone, you'd have to see the place where it was, that little tan line where the watch was? Would you want to still accept that watch when it would feel safer to not have it at all?
这有点像是如果有人给你一份精美的礼物，比如他们给了你一块精美的手表。然后他们说，嘿，我可能随时把它拿走。当把它拿走时，我就直接去抢你。你会接受那块手表吗？你会想把它戴在手腕上，这样当它没了之后，你还得看着它曾待过的地方，那个手表曾在那里的晒痕？你还想接受那块手表吗，即使不拥有它会感到更安全？
Right after the semester finished, DeSantis signed his big higher ed package. That final law did not have some of the things the professors I spoke with found most alarming. They dropped the idea that no one could major or minor in gender studies or feminist theory or critical race theory. They dropped the idea that unruly professors could have their tenure reviewed at any time.
学期刚结束，德桑蒂斯签署了他的大型高等教育一揽子计划。那部最终法律并没有包含我交谈过的教授们认为最令人担忧的一些东西。他们放弃了没有人能主修或辅修性别研究、女性主义理论或批判性种族理论的想法。他们放弃了不守规矩的教授可以随时被审查终身职位的想法。
But the law does say that in general education courses, you can't teach identity politics or that systemic racism or sexism are built into the institutions of the United States. Kaysin saw the news about the bill passing and thought about her future. They're not going to stop here, she told me. Who knows what further restrictions to higher education they might make next year? Would you want to stick around for that?
但法律确实说，在通识教育课程中，你不能教授身份政治，或者不能教授系统性种族主义或性别歧视是美国制度的内在组成部分。凯辛看到了关于法案通过的新闻，想到了她的未来。他们不会在这里停止，她告诉我。谁知道明年他们还会对高等教育做出什么进一步的限制？你会想留下来面对吗？
It's a thing she's talking about a lot nowadays with the people in her life, with her friends, with her parents, just what staying or leaving would mean, especially as a Black person in the South.
这是她现在和她生活中的人们、朋友、父母谈论很多的事情，关于留下或离开意味着什么，特别是在南方作为一个黑人。
I was in that particular headspace when I went to my dad. And I was like, I think I need to get out of this state. I don't think I should stay here whatsoever. I don't feel safe. And he took that in. Then he was to me, like, but we don't run from things like that.
当我去找我父亲时，我处于那种特定的心态中。我说，我想我需要离开这个州。我不认为我应该留在这里。我不觉得安全。他听进去了。然后他对我像是，但我们不躲避那样的事情。
And I was like, dude, what are you talking about? And he was like, we're Black people. We're living in the South. If we left every time we felt threatened, no one would be here right now. And it was just this idea of, when people are trying to scare you away, you don't just go along with it. You don't do them the favor of leaving.
我说，伙计，你在说什么？他说，我们是黑人。我们生活在南方。如果我们每次感到受到威胁都离开，现在这里一个人都不会留下了。这只是一种想法，当人们试图把你吓走时，你不要只是顺从它。你不要帮他们离开。
You stay, and you try to make things right. And if you do leave, it's because you found something that you definitely know is better. You leave for you, not for them.
你留下来，努力纠正事情。如果你确实离开，那是因为你发现了一些你绝对确定更好的东西。你为你自己而离开，而不是为了他们。
Whether or not Kaysin stays in Florida through grad school, the one thing she knows for sure is that she still wants to be a professor, just like Dr. Gaines. The new law didn't change that.
无论凯辛是否在佛罗里达州读完研究生，她唯一确定的是她仍然想成为一名教授，就像盖恩斯博士一样。新法律并没有改变这一点。
It did have a chilling effect. But what that looks like right now among the professors I talk to is people feeling fear, maybe changing their course names or removing things from their CVs. But mostly, these educators are standing their ground and teaching the same things they were before.
它确实产生了寒蝉效应。但在我交谈过的教授中，这目前看起来像是人们感到恐惧，可能会改变课程名称或从他们的简历中删除一些东西。但大多数情况下，这些教育工作者们坚持阵地，教授着他们以前教的内容。
Dr. Gaines, for instance, that class about major American writers, she decided to go ahead and teach only Black authors from the Harlem Renaissance. Dr. Celia Caputi is moving ahead with her article referencing the lesbian continuum. The faculty union is telling everyone, don't change your classes. If they try to use the law to stop you, we'll fight.
例如，盖恩斯博士那门关于美国主要作家的课，她决定继续只教哈莱姆文艺复兴时期的黑人作家。西莉亚·卡普蒂博士正在继续进行她关于女同性恋连续体的文章。教师工会告诉每个人，不要改变你的课程。如果他们试图利用法律来阻止你，我们会斗争。
Reporter Emmanuel Dzotsi.
记者伊曼纽尔·佐齐。
Act three, Goodbye Sunshine.
第三幕，再见阳光。
So here's my bedroom. My suitcase is out on my bed, and then I just have three boxes left to unpack-- actually, no, two boxes left to unpack.
好了，这是我的卧室。我的手提箱在床上，然后我只有三个箱子没拆——事实上，不，还有两个箱子没拆。
So we started our show with people moving to Florida. We end with somebody moving away. Eliza's 16, just finished her sophomore year of high school. And I talked to her two days after she arrived in the house her family just moved to in Virginia.
所以我们以人们搬到佛罗里达州开始了我们的节目。我们以某人搬走而结束。伊丽莎（Eliza）16 岁，刚上完高中二年级。我在她搬进她在弗吉尼亚州的新房子的两天后和她交谈。
They moved because of the law that Ron DeSantis enacted in May that bans gender-affirming care for anybody under 18. Eliza's trans, takes a hormone blocker, an estrogen.
他们搬家是因为罗恩·德桑蒂斯在五月制定的法律，禁止 18 岁以下的人进行性别肯定护理。伊丽莎是跨性别者，服用激素阻断剂，雌激素。
Yeah, it was just, the a concern is that I wouldn't be able to get the care that I needed. So we had to move somewhere where we knew that that wouldn't be threatened, at least for another couple of years.
是的，只是，担心我无法获得我需要的护理。所以我们必须搬到某个地方，我们知道那至少在未来几年内不会受到威胁。
Eliza's dad is in the military, so she's moved around a lot, Ohio, Texas, Germany, Los Angeles, Huntsville, Montgomery, been to lots of schools. She says, usually there's an even split between people who believe different kinds of things, but not in her school in Florida.
伊丽莎的父亲在军队服役，所以她经常搬家，俄亥俄州、得克萨斯州、德国、洛杉矶、亨茨维尔、蒙哥马利，去过很多学校。她说，通常在相信不同事情的人之间会有均等的划分，但在她在佛罗里达州的学校里却没有。
It was just very-- I feel like the entire scale was shifted to the right. I feel like even the most progressive people at my school were still way, way less progressive than any other place that I've been in before. It's just so casual, just really common, really normal to just be awful and then to be exclusionary to people.
它只是非常——我觉得整个天平向右倾斜了。我觉得即使是我学校里最进步的人，也比我以前去过的任何其他地方都进步得多，得多。这太随意了，非常普遍，非常正常，只是变得糟糕，然后排斥别人。
But I just got kind of used to it. I don't know. Florida's just going to be Florida.
但我只是习惯了。我不知道。佛罗里达州注定就是佛罗里达州。
We're putting this interview with you-- our conversation that we're having right now-- into an episode of our show that begins with people who moved to Florida because they liked the politics there. And I wonder, when you hear that, what do you think of people like that?
我们正在把你这次采访——我们现在正在进行的对话——放入我们节目的一集中，这一集以那些因为喜欢那里的政治而搬到佛罗里达州的人开始。我想知道，当你听到这些时，你会怎么看待那些人？
Um, I think that is a crazy thing to hear. And it just shows-- I don't know. I feel like-- congratulations, that the things that are being threatened every day don't affect you. You're lucky. But that's not the case for me, and that's not the case for a lot of people.
嗯，我觉得那是很疯狂的事情。这只是表明——我不知道。我觉得——恭喜，那些每天受到威胁的事情不会影响你。你很幸运。但对我来说不是这样，对很多人来说也不是这样。
Parts of the law that made Eliza move have been overturned by the courts. But that doesn't matter to her family. Eliza wasn't out to many people in Florida. Most kids at school didn't know she was trans. So when she had to explain to them the reason why she was leaving, she kept it simple. "Politics," she said.
那项让伊丽莎搬家的法律的部分内容已被法院推翻。但这对她的家庭来说并不重要。伊丽莎在佛罗里达州没有向许多人出柜。学校里大多数孩子都不知道她是跨性别者。所以当她不得不向他们解释她离开的原因时，她说得很简单。“政治，”她说。
Well, our program was produced today by Zoe Chace and Alaa Mostafa.
好了，我们的节目今天由佐伊·蔡斯和阿拉·穆斯塔法（Alaa Mostafa）制作。
The people put together today's show include Bim Adewunmi, Chris Benderev, James Bennett II, Phia Bennin, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Bethel Habte, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Seth Lind, Caitlin Love, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu.
今天把节目凑在一起的人包括 Bim Adewunmi、Chris Benderev、James Bennett II、Phia Bennin、Sean Cole、Michael Comite、Aviva DeKornfeld、Bethel Habte、Cassie Howley、Valerie Kipnis、Seth Lind、Caitlin Love、Stowe Nelson、Katherine Rae Mondo、Nadia Reiman、Ryan Rumery、Alissa Shipp、Lilly Sullivan、Christopher Swetala、Matt Tierney 和 Diane Wu。
Managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emmanuele Berry. Ike Sriskandarajah produced act three of our show.
执行主编是 Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的高级编辑是 David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是 Emmanuele Berry。Ike Sriskandarajah 制作了我们节目的第三幕。
Special thanks today to Paul Westcott of L2 Data, Devan Vilfrard, Jacob Perry, Dominique Jean Louis, Taylor Cox, John Gregory, Laurel Bristow, the National Conference of State Legislatures, Julio Ochoa, Stephanie Colombini, Earle Kimel, Paul Offit, Kim Savage, Rob Brooks, Ann Davies, Christopher Spata from The Tampa Bay Times, Zac Anderson from the Sarasota Herald-Tribune, Tho Bishop, Paul and Brenda Chabot, Selene San Felice, Adam Steinbaugh, Aubrey Jewett, Susan MacManus, and Julia Manchester and Max Greenwood, who wrote about Florida turning red for The Hill.
今天特别感谢 L2 Data 的 Paul Westcott、Devan Vilfrard、Jacob Perry、Dominique Jean Louis、Taylor Cox、John Gregory、Laurel Bristow、全国州议会会议、Julio Ochoa、Stephanie Colombini、Earle Kimel、Paul Offit、Kim Savage、Rob Brooks、Ann Davies、《坦帕湾时报》的 Christopher Spata、《萨拉索塔先驱论坛报》的 Zac Anderson、Tho Bishop、Paul 和 Brenda Chabot、Selene San Felice、Adam Steinbaugh、Aubrey Jewett、Susan MacManus，以及为《国会山报》撰写关于佛罗里达州变红的 Julia Manchester 和 Max Greenwood。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where we have new merch, including great new T-shirts and more. My favorite is this really beautiful illustration of our show's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. Check it out, thisamericanlife.org.
《美国生活》通过公共广播交流中心 PRX 提供给公共广播电台。我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，我们在那里有新的商品，包括很棒的新 T 恤等等。我最喜欢的是我们节目联合创始人 Torey Malatia 先生这张非常漂亮的插图。去看看吧，thisamericanlife.org。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He refuses to go to dinner and a movie with me if it's just the two of us. And here's why.
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人 Torey Malatia 先生。如果只有我们俩，他拒绝和我一起出去吃饭看电影。这就是原因。
I don't believe in man dates.
我不相信强制令（man-dates）。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。